testing one two this is your one minute
heads up this meeting will start in one
minute
okay
okay good morning everyone let's get
this meeting started this is the Monday
morning session of science technology
and energy for the 13th of March 2023
and as usual we will begin to our
meeting by all standing and joining
representative Summers as he leads us in
the Pledge of Allegiance
thank you
okay thank you and good morning everyone
today we've got a packed lineup we're
going to start by resuming the public
hearing on House Bill 609
We Will Follow That by resuming the
public hearing on House Bill 142.
at the conclusion of both of those
meetings we will be
holding an executive session on five
bills
that are listed in the calendar
including House Bill 609 and House Bill
142. those are the these five bills are
the final five bills that this committee
has to
come to a resolution about
before the house deadline
for
deliberating on bills arrives
so we hope to get all that work done
today we'll stay as long as needed
if it's necessary we will take a lunch
break and then come back after lunch
so with that I'd like to reopen the
public hearing on House Bill 609.
and now let's go over the ground rules
for how we're going to hold this resumed
public hearing
we have over a dozen pink cards
that have been submitted so I will be
consistently
requesting that everybody limit their
testimony to three minutes
and I will enforce that three-minute
limit
I also request that you only present
information to the committee that we
have not already heard
please don't repeat stuff that we heard
if you were here last Monday
if you weren't here last Monday you
probably don't know what was said so you
may end up repeating yourself but I will
give you a heads up if I think that
that's the case
so with those ground rules in place we
can now start the public hearing
and I will call first on the honorable
Neil Kirk to give us his perspective on
the proposed legislation and before rep
the former representative Kirk begins
his testimony I want to point out that
there is an extensive Amendment
under preparation at the office of
legislative Services even as we speak
and this extensive
amendment makes numerous changes
to the bill
as presented or as introduced and also
makes numerous changes to the amendment
that I discussed at the initial public
hearing for this bill
some of the big changes that have been
made include the addition of two public
members to the Public Utilities
Commission
process
the change in application fees
and other changes
that were necessary to support the two
changes that I just missed mentioned so
there are extensive changes coming on
the bill
and
I'm hopeful that those changes will lead
to some bipartisan support so that we
can move this bill forward
and with that I'll now look forward to
hearing the comments of our esteemed
former colleague
Kirk it's all yours Neil nice to see you
by the way same here Mr chairman good
morning to you sir and to members of the
committee for the record I'm Neil Kirk I
live in Ware and I'm representing myself
it's good to see so many of you back and
doing the right thing
with respect to this bill it contains
The Good The Bad and The Ugly
the good is that it attempts to
rationalize and shorten a process of
approving energy
um
developments which currently takes far
far too long we can't spend years
approving these kinds of things it needs
to be done quickly and this bill is a
really good start in speeding up the
process
if you can do anything to speed it up
even further kudos to you
the bad
this bill
puts in Char it puts the Public
Utilities Commission in charge of making
decisions for which it cannot
institutionally do a good job and that
is considering the public interest in a
way that the SEC has done
this in effect abolishes the SEC
and lets the Public Utilities Commission
do that work
there are a whole variety of ways that
it does this but that's the essence and
the problem with that is that you've got
a A administrative institution the puc
whose job is to improve power and make
power available making decisions in an
area which would say no we can't do it
that way
and that's wrong
consolidating power in administrative
agency is something that you expect in a
planned economy
this needs to be divided up and the puc
function retained by an independent body
but that can be done under the
jurisdiction of the puc if it's all
coordinated and there's a timeline
the ugly
there is a strong suspicion amongst a
lot of people
the Northern Pass folk and I was one of
those who opposed northern pass that
this is a
backdoor effort to get Northern Pass in
through a change that in effect
eliminates the power of the SEC
that's a suspicion that's a fear
but just so you know it's real
the good I encourage you to continue and
strengthen the bad you've got to figure
out some way to get the public making a
decision that's not being made by the
puc Commissioners they are not the right
body to make that decision and the bad
well we'll see what happens Mr chairman
I would hope the committee retains this
bill
especially if this new Amendment does
not comply with the criteria that I've
suggested and work to make it better but
the good needs to survive this process
we need to speed up the way in which
these projects are approved thank you Mr
chairman
I'd be pleased to answer questions if
the committee has any thank you
two minutes 50 seconds appreciate you
staying within our
our guidelines any questions from the
committee that's a record for me Mr
chairman by the way
representative Harrington has a question
not too much of a question maybe an
answer to one was raised I can assure
you that there is no uh back door Secret
Squirrel whatever you want to call it
attempted getting uh Northern Pass
approved via the change to the site
evaluation committee it's uh we've had
hearings on this we had commission
hearings that is not the position that
is not the op this is not what we're
trying to accomplish we're trying to
make the process work better not nothing
to do with Northern Pass
thank you Mr representative Harrington I
appreciate that
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so if I may ask then
your
what is your
opinion on
what took so long to make a previous
decision in in the process and how do we
avoid that again
thank you for that question I think the
timelines were too generous number one
and I think it would be better if a lot
of the necessary
parts to the approval process didn't
happen in sequential order but happened
simultaneously with the puc the last to
make the final decision but each of the
components the environmental the SEC
type has to occur simultaneously and
timelines have to be shortened
see no further questions from the
committee I want to thank you for being
here thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming in today next we'll call on Mr
Fred Ward
who is from Stoddard and is representing
himself Mr Ward I'm going to use the
word snooker it does not refer to the
game
thank you
um first thing I want to be sure you
understand that this 609 is a
replacement for 162h which has been
around for a long time and we're here
today because the site evaluation
committee and the Public Utilities
Commission and I have to say I don't
distinguish between them because the
members have moved they've interfered
they've moved from one to another
they've moved their jobs and things so
when I say SEC and puc as far as I'm
concerned and as far as what we could
see over 14 years of dealing with them
we can't distinguish between them I'm
sure there's a difference
okay we were snookered like that's the
word I want to use by the SEC puc
we worked with them
we tried everything
and they snook at us we turn to the your
chairman in hoping that he could do
something and he certainly volunteered
and worked hard but then it ended up
that they snuck at him too
so we're all sitting here and I think
most of us if you ask us what the
problem is it was they didn't deal with
us
we could say things I could disagree
totally with this guy over here
no questions asked
there's a Japanese word for it called
moku satsu and it translates as ignore
them and they'll go away and that's what
they did over the entire time they never
did for example some obvious things and
I'll just mention two of them which have
been going on for many years
one of the things that we complained
about I think it was a group in around
and from New Hampshire was the noise at
night from the turbans
now it has to be according to law less
than 40 decibels
I can't tell you what 40 decibels is but
it's pretty loud
now in order to do that you have to
measure the damn thing
more than that since the The Sounds vary
all over the place from very light to
very strong
you have to watch what the weather is
doing because the weather determines the
sound and everybody knows including and
from wind and including the SEC and the
puc
that this you need strong winds to make
the noise at the turbine and then you
need to put a cap on it it's a
meteorological it's a weather cap such
that you trap the noise then
everybody knows that that will produce
the loudest sound
so any logical
expression any group that was going to
come in and say we never go above 40 DB
at night would have to make the
measurements on those nights
you have to know what the hell those
nights are
asked I asked and I asked
and the Not only did the Antrim win not
make the measurements
but that they were never required by the
SEC puc the measurements have not ever
been made which would show whether they
did or didn't violate the law the noise
rule the second thing if you all you got
to do is go buy them the red flashing
lights are on half the time
there aren't that many planes over there
they're supposed to have a system
and from wind isn't going to put the
system in but you would think that you
would have the SEC puc where we keep
breaking them in and they you wonder why
there's so much time spent because we're
in court half the time
that's a problem so I can complain and
tell you all the things that they didn't
do
but the problem is that the the public
people the SEC puc never ask them to do
what any clown would know enough to do
we come away I think if you talk to the
people here I don't want to say I'm
speaking for a little bit I think I am
the frustration was that we could never
get an answer they never asked the
question they never did the things that
they had to do
and they didn't and that's the problem
with this and you need to turn down 609
just because it doesn't do anything
about that 30 seconds please pardon
30 seconds please
okay
oh 30 seconds
I'm one one last sentence
if you let a bankrupt come into a bank
you don't hand them the key and that's
what's going on with 609 thank you
thank you questions for Mr Ward
seeing none I want to thank you for your
testimony this morning and I'll call
next on Mr Timothy Duggan
of Thornton New Hampshire to give us his
perspective on this proposed legislation
good morning my name is Tim Duggan I
live in Thornton New Hampshire
I spent 15 years in the United States
military in service to my country and my
state I was a cold warrior I spent most
of my time training to fight the Soviet
Union wherever they threatened our
democracy and our way of life
if the Soviets had gotten their way we'd
all be living under their system where
the state makes all the decisions and
the citizens are forced to comply with
them
I was here Tuesday there's more than 10
different speakers explained why
citizens like me should give up our
stake in the decisions that impact our
homes in our lives I heard over and over
that these decisions be better made by
the state because it would be more
efficient and more professional when two
political appointees in Concord make
these decisions for us
I'm also a 10-year veteran of another
fight the battle of the northern pass
of the many lessons I learned in that
fight one seems particularly relevant
today
it always starts with a lie
it's tough to pinpoint the actual first
Northern Pass lie there were so many of
them I'll pick one
we need it to keep the lights on
they used to tell us that lie while they
showed us pictures of babies and
incubators
well we haven't had the northern pass
for 13 years
the lights are still on
those babies in the incubators are
getting ready to go to high school
could I interrupt you just a second for
just a second could you not
re-litigate the Northern Pass issue
since it's already been settled and just
give us new information about hb609 I
really appreciate it thank you
appreciate it thank you
so now it's starting again
it always starts with a lie
today there are two lies the first lies
what's known in propaganda as the big
lie a big lie is something is so
counter-intuitive that people can't
imagine someone would actually lie about
it
eventually big lies are accepted as
truths because they've been repeated so
often people just treat them as fact
the big lie here is that the SEC is the
problem
over and over we hear that the SEC is
the problem the SEC wasn't the reason
the Northern Pass founded for 10 years
those delays were caused by an
incomplete project plan riddled with
fundamental flaws that were not
addressed in the permitting process
those ambiguities and flaws festered for
years from the SEC with its public
component acted relatively quickly to
produce its ruling the SEC was the one
part of the process that actually worked
and hb609 will do away with it in the
name of efficiency and professionalism
the SEC may not be perfect but it
absolutely is not the problem in fact
for Northern press the SEC was the
solution
the second lies was formerly known as
paltering which is the active use of
selected truthful statements in order to
mislead
when confronted with the fact that the
public will lose its decision-making
power proponents of hb609 repeat the
Mantra that all of the public input has
been retained
telling us that we still have input when
we're talking about the actual decision
is a lie
the irony of the public potentially
losing our stake in these decisions
isn't lost on me after all those years
spent trained to fight the forces that
threaten my way of life I actually find
myself doing it right here in Concord
New Hampshire
I urge you to vote in expedient to
legislate on this bill to preserve the
public stake and the decisions that
impact our homes and our lives
thank you for your time happy to take
questions
thank you appreciate that uh testimony
questions from the committee
representative Christian
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um so just to make sure that I
understand you're saying that we need to
retain some members of the public on the
actual voting decision-making body for
you to feel confident that the public
has real input into the process
absolutely correct thank you
the amendment that's under preparation
does exactly that
further questions for the committee
seeing none I want to thank you for
coming in today thank you I'll call next
upon and I'm going to apologize in
advance because I'm sure I'm going to
mispronounce this but
it looks like Darlene King Jennings
did I get it right or not you got it no
good thank you thank you
and welcome
three minutes please thank you
um I am going to try to revise my
statements I'm not a public speaker and
I had my whole thing all set up to
um before this uh Amendment which we
don't know anything about
and we don't know how many people in in
the public are going to get put back on
um and I am going to say that I was an
opposition of the northern path by the
way my name is Darlene King Jennings I'm
from Campton and I want to reiterate
what Mr Dugan said from Thornton the
Northern Pass is relevant to this
because the bottom line is this we got
two major lies in the beginning process
of this and we're getting the same lives
the the except for that they've been
revised enough so that it their today's
lies the lies back then were we need
jobs we need power
we didn't need power back then because
the power we made more than power than
what we needed
we did we needed
not jobs that were power company jobs we
needed real jobs that would stay in New
Hampshire so now you guys are are
presenting this
um as we need cheaper power well the puc
was the one that just put in
a huge increase in our power
you know that timing is amazing
it's amazing and you want to put them in
charge of this
the second lie is that that power is
needed for the good paying jobs to come
into New Hampshire which is a take off
on we needed the power we needed the
jobs that the power company was going to
bring in to us
so it's still the same ball of wax
you're just trying to con us into
believing that we
we you don't need our vote and that the
the the people who sat on the committee
were not educated enough
to know what they were doing and all the
other organizations didn't have the
funding to be able to to give enough
time to make it very inefficient so why
aren't you looking at making it
efficient instead of getting rid of the
people's voice 30 seconds please I'm I'm
done thank you
okay thank you very much
questions from the committee
seeing none
I'll call next on Susan Ford from
she'll tell us where she's from maybe
it's Easton
welcome Ms Ford
The Honorable Susan Ford I'm sorry
and for the record my name is Sue Ford
and I live in
a small town north of Franconia notch
you need that closer for you thank you
as a former representative I know many
of you on the committee but I'm here
before you today with my new title
a member of the public
I can assure you that that title isn't
isn't welcome since hb609 and its
Amendment sets out to eliminate my voice
I was concerned about the hearing last
Monday supporters of hb609 were allowed
to speak and take all the time they
wanted when we were on the second hour
there was a question if the opponents of
this bill would be given an adequate
amount of time to respond this is just
another indication that the public is
losing its voice when I was in the house
I took my responses and act and actions
to support and help my constituents
seriously
a year from now there may be a sighting
project in your town what answer will
you give when a constituent asks about
the process to be appointed to the
Review Committee
oh we don't do that operate that way
anymore I voted against meaningful
participation of the public
I would like to remind you all that ship
has sailed the public wants and requires
us to involve them so that they have a
meaningful say in the community and I
like to add I don't think you need to be
a legislator to know the difference
between May and shell
I know we all skated around the topic
last week and everyone talked about that
project much too long the reality is
that the northern project past project
did take a long time agreeing on the
rules took a long time but those rules
are in place now I suspect that now that
we've completed the process they may
need some revision I haven't looked at
the rules for several years but there
also may be some adjustments for smaller
projects but the foundation is there
has it been mentioned that there was a
change in the path of the northern pass
project and had to be adjusted then
there were the changes for the 60 miles
of burial
not to mention that there were over 30
towns involved
of course it took a long time to go
through that process
I can't think of any project except
maybe rural electrification that
involved as many New Hampshire towns
I find it outrageous that you are
promoting that this SEC currently with
nine members represented in important
areas and now allowing the puc with
three members with a quorum of two to
make citing decisions even the council
for the public is optional and the New
Hampshire agencies would be reduced to
voluntary consultative status
we deserve better and I believe you will
hear that from members of the public
across the state this issue has already
been reported in our free newspapers
that was not initiated by me I believe
one of the reporters picked up the issue
from the New Hampshire Bulletin
I urge you to to recommend itl or
retention on hb609
yeah thank you questions from the
committee representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair
um thank you for being here honorable
Ford it's always good to see you a point
of clarification
um do you see gas pipe projects being
rammed through in New Hampshire as a
result of passing this bill that's
another option of course okay if the
public does not have a view in this I
mean I'm seriously believed that ship
has sailed the public needs to have
of boys
thank you
further questions representative partial
thank you chair
and welcome
could you please tell me uh
do you think it's a concern for the
people of New Hampshire and for us our
election body the fact that we're gonna
I understand there's Amendment on this
bill that will come before the executive
committee and without any public
testimony whatsoever will be voted on
that is concerning to every single
person in this room I hope
thank you
further questions representative Doug
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
uh thank you for taking my question uh
in relation to the pre to the previous
representative's question are you aware
that the rules uh prevent us from
discussing amendments during uh public
hearing of the basic Bill until
executive session opens and a motion is
made on the basic Bill and only then can
discussions be made on the amendment yes
I do that do know that but I served on
the finance committee and I will tell
you right now that whenever we had a
bill come before us in one of that fit
either house as committee one two or
three we discuss those amendments we
tore them up and down one side and the
other so that we could make sure that we
were doing what was right for the public
if you want to stay this afternoon and
have an or next week and have an
amendment discussion and a hearing on
the amendment I'll be glad to look it
over and come back
follow up
follow up so you agree that we have to
open up the exact session first before
we can discuss the amendment which has
no limit for discussions
you can do you want what you want I've
read the amendment I didn't see that
much change
just so you know and I'm not I'm not
convinced that everybody has read the
amendment in this room
representative
Oregon has a question thank you very
much Mary Mr chair
um you may and may not be aware of this
so I may just have to ask whether you
believe it but would you are you aware
that in my community we had
a somewhat smaller project but still
controversial uh the well we nicknamed
it the southern pass but the Seacoast
reliability project which ran from
Madbury to Newington and uh would you
believe that in fact the SEC did a very
thorough you know digital uh routine uh
did a very thorough review of the
project had many many hearings and
information sessions and in fact in that
case they actually did approve the
project with some changes and actually
did get built so thank you
representative I do remember that
project and I remember it was going on
at the same time as Northern Pass was
going on and we all watched it for the
expediency and the work that they put
into that so thank you
representative Wendy Thomas has another
question thank you Mr chair actually
this is a point of clarification
um representative Douglas Thomas just
reminded us that we have to open up the
amendment in exec in an executive
session before we can discuss it however
we've already heard from the chair who
is the sponsor of this uh Bill details
regarding the amendment so do we either
what is what is what is the course of
action do we discuss the amendment or do
we not discuss the amendment thank you I
had a long discussion with the house
clerk about this issue
and he said that you can talk in general
terms about an amendment you can't talk
about the specific language of the
amendment until executive session
follow-up follow-up
um and is the amendment available for
the public to read at this point
it will be very shortly I'm waiting for
OLS to complete the final changes that
were made
unfortunately we had a weekend that
intervened which slowed down the process
a little bit but hopefully those changes
will be available within an hour
thank you
Mr chairman we also know that the public
has no voice as your executive sessions
that is concerning
that's the way the process I do know
that I said I'm sure you're well aware
okay further questions for The Honorable
Ms Ford
seeing none I want to thank you thank
you
next I'll call on
Ray Breslin of Londonderry
good morning Mr Breslin three minutes
please
good morning uh Ray president Donald
Londonderry and I'm not a public speaker
uh but
um what we're discussing here is
extremely important and
um there's a really big picture
um when we're talking about energy
um with a lot of sources of energy
and we need to look at all of them
um
I'm not going to get into a northern
pass because
um
I don't know as much about it as a
perhaps I should but
um
what we have here is a situation where
we export energy out of state okay
if we used all the energy we made in the
state of New Hampshire we'd have plenty
of energy but yet we're being told
um
when uh
eversource comes to the state of New
Hampshire and tells us that we're going
to have rolling blackouts
because there's a shortage of energy
that's of concern and when we have power
plants down to Newington and Portsmouth
that are in a situation of basically
from what I see uh sort of like
mothballs I could be wrong but when I go
down there and take a look I don't see
any activity whatsoever
and are those plants to sitting there
now wait a minute some of those plants
are supposed to be
uh Pico plants
that uh when is of New England calls up
and says we need some more power here
and fire up your plant
well those plants have to be ready to go
at a moment's notice
uh they can't be uh just sitting there
cold uh takes a long time to bring a
turban or a boiler up to temperature so
you can put it online
that's not peaking power yet some of
these plants are being paid as
um spinning Reserve peaking uh which
means they need to need to be available
at a moment's notice
if we got plants sitting here in New
Hampshire and not being used
properly
uh we've got some concerns
look
production of power it is a lot of
things we can have wind we can have
hydro we can have fossil fuel plants we
can have wood chip plants which
unfortunately wood chip plants in New
Hampshire apparently are found to be not
useful uh not uh economically feasible
30 seconds please
um we have School departments in the
state of New Hampshire that have wood
chip plants we have uh schools and
municipal buildings in the state of New
Hampshire have
I have uh
have wood pellet plants those folks have
done their studies and they find that
those who are economically feasible to
produce heat for the buildings for
schools and municipalities uh by the way
um okay Mr Breslin you're starting to
stray from this topic and you've reached
your time limit so I want to thank you
for for being here and ask you to wrap
up in the next uh 10 seconds please okay
uh if the point is this uh this this is
a very important subject I agree we need
to really look at this
um but we need to know
um we need to have the the public
involved we need to have a lot of people
on the Public Utility Commission
involved and doing away with the site
evaluation committee is a problem
okay thank you very much
any questions for Mr Breslin
seeing none I'll call next on Mr Wayne
King of bath
please turn on the microphone
see we didn't have these 40 years ago
40 years ago I sat in your seat
as a young freshman legislator
as it happened I was a few months before
that I was sitting
in front of the Plymouth State College
Union building with a fellow I just met
named Michael Hutchings
and another fellow that you may know
some of you anyway named Ray Burton
walked up to me
and Michael
and he handed us each a dollar
and he said you go register to run for
the legislature Ray didn't know what our
party was
as it turned out Michael was a
Republican and I was a Democrat
but we were both sedan broke that
Michael used to joke that I could make a
chicken go seven days
I'm still pretty good at that by the way
um
anyway Michael and I we were we were
because we were broke we carpooled to
Concord together
and we learn to talk to each other
which is something that is badly needed
right now between the Democrats and the
Republicans
he became
my best friend to this day
uh
and we talked about everything and we
used to come down to the legislature and
we used to work our committee I was on
this committee on Edna and we were
reorganizing state government at the
time under the current Governor's father
and
Ray Burton when he gave us that dollar
he said I'm not ever going to ask you
how I'm not ever going to tell you how
you should vote what I am going to tell
you is do not let the legislative
process Rob the citizens of their voice
so I'm here
to oppose this bill not only for me but
for Ray
and I I I I have to associate my remarks
with my fellow colleague from those days
Neil Kirk and you would almost never
hear me saying that when we were in the
legislature together
yet Neil Kirk was probably one of the
most respected members of the
legislature by both political parties
when he was here 30 seconds please we
cannot Rob the citizens of their voice
and two more two more people on the puc
that can't function as it is is not
going to do that and this response is
the kind of response that you would
expect from president XI of China as
opposed to the president of the United
States
okay thank you any uh questions for The
Honorable Mr King
seeing none I want to thank you for
being here this morning and giving us
your perspective next we'll call on Mark
Sanborn from the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental secured
Services rather
good morning assistant commissioner
Sanborn
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record Mark
Sanborn assistant commissioner New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services I spoke last Monday so I won't
repeat
um I just I'll be very brief
um I do feel compelled to say based on
some things that have been said today no
agency in the state is giving up any
Authority Under This
the if there is a permit or approval
required through another part of the
state this bill keeps that intact
anything that has to go through the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services will still have to go through
so statements to the contrary or
statements that agencies are giving up
any of their Authority or
responsibilities are simply inaccurate
the second thing I'd like to make clear
is if you support renewable energy you
should support this bill
the the the
Legacy generators who already have an
investment in New Hampshire
have a reason to fight through the
ineffective SEC process they already
have enough invested here that they will
continue to work through the process
regardless if you are starting with zero
dollars of investment right now you will
not come here because it costs too much
money to get through the process so you
will go to another state that has a more
efficient And Timely
um citing process
and to to do your business so if you
believe New Hampshire needs more
renewable energy generation the best
thing you can do is improve the
efficiency and the timeliness and the
cost of getting through the citing
process
those are the two things I wanted to
comment on Mr chairman
thank you representative Wendy Thomas
has a question for you thank you Mr
chair
um I think you just testified that you
testified on this last week is that I
did yep
um who gave you permission to testify
again today
I myself okay follow up with a chair
please
what is your follow-up he doesn't need
permission to be here so are are you
going to allow people who testified last
week to to testify again today if need
be if they have something new to add
okay thank you for that clarification
representative Christian has a question
question
my question thank you chair thank you
for taking my question
um can you just comment how many
projects are before the SEC right now
and how many of them are renewable
uh I'm not the admit that perhaps a
better question for the SEC
administrator
um I don't know for sure but I have
heard uh obviously speaking about
renewable energy is an extremely part
important part of the environmental
conversation so in talking with many
developers of renewable energy and the
folks who support renewable energy I can
tell you that one of the number things
they come and tell you is it is too hard
to get through the citing process to do
business in New Hampshire one of the
best examples used and it's been brought
up a number of times today how long did
it take Antrim wind which in in in in
speaking of energy projects is actually
fairly small project to get through the
process it took an enormous amount of
time much more than was needed to
evaluate the pros and cons of that
project
may I follow up follow-up so my
understanding is there's at least two
dozen large-scale solar projects
underway so I feel like if you're going
to make the assertion that
there's not projects coming you should
have the data to back that up thank you
no there yes and they're frustrated with
how long the process takes and the fact
that they can't get through the SEC
process in a way to actually get their
infrastructure built inside it and one
other quick thing Mr chairman
um
the uh it was mentioned earlier about
the lack of follow-up through the SEC in
terms of enforcement of the conditions
of certificate again this bill addresses
that it actually gives a staff and and
gives the uh adjudicative body and the
folks responsible for compliancy
um the staff and uh hopefully the
necessary budget to actually do that
work the problem is right now the SEC
um as currently constructed is a staff
of one
um and doesn't have any budget beyond
the money for just that staffer's salary
so there is no ability
for True for that individual to
effectively do the follow-up so again if
you want if you're a believer in
compliancy of uh for their certificates
that are cited in this process you again
should support this bill because it
gives the resources needed to do that
thank you I appreciate that
representative Doug Thomas has a
question for you thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question so for
clarification
um because because you mentioned it
um
how is it if it if true and I don't know
if it's true because we haven't heard
from I guess puc
if it's true that we have so many
projects that have been submitted but
haven't been acted upon yet
why have they been submitted if if
everyone feels the process is
too long and disinviting to invest in in
the state I'm I'm confused please yeah
because folks do want to do business
here in New Hampshire the the renewable
uh energy industry does want to do this
we you know I don't want to get into an
energy conversation Mr chairman to a bit
30 seconds folks have to remember we are
on a grid we are on a 60 grid not on an
individual State grid so
the the con the conversation about how
where exporters or importers is it's
really about the cost to the ratepayers
for energy in the available
uh energy created in the grid not just
in our state so uh you you you can't
have an energy conversation whether it
be generation use or cost without first
starting with the fact that we're in a
multi-state grid so there is a lot of
interest in doing business here in New
Hampshire what I will say is probably
the reason there are over two dozen
applications and is because the SEC as
currently constructured can't meet can't
have Quorum and start you can't start to
adjudicate those applications so again
I'm I I'm excited and supportive of the
amount of applications I want them to
actually be able to get through a
process is that allows them to be
reviewed and
um and decided on in a manner that will
actually lead to more energy generation
in the state
foreign
Brown has a question uh thank you Mr
chair I'd I'd like to follow up on
representative Thomas's comment
um as a retired state worker I I will
tell you I am proud of every day that I
put into work for the state of New
Hampshire
and I am also proud of how everyone I
worked with how hard they worked
so to follow up on that I want to ask
you a specific question if the
commissioner of Des is not in
or he's unavailable who makes the
decisions at the department
I'm next in line of succession thank you
are there questions representative Wendy
Thomas I'll remind you that we are here
to ask questions to gather information
not to engage in debate yeah all right
well well I've message received thank
you very much
um so
um one of my my uh points of confusion
is you you just said that the the
process currently takes too long however
last week we heard that this would not
affect the timeline it would sort it
would instead quote streamline the
process
um how how do you square those two uh
statements pretty easily it's not about
changing the official timelines as
written in statute it's about changing
the effectiveness of the structure and
adjudicive body that hears those
decisions the problem right now isn't
how long it takes for uh an applicant to
submit their information or how long it
is to review the problem is the SEC
can't even meet in a regular basis the
SEC doesn't even have the ability to
function I mean you know just breaking
this down regardless of how you feel
about any of these issues the SEC does
not function properly it can't meet
there are members who have never shown
up to a meeting
this the the current structure of the
SEC is broken that's the New Hampshire
Department of energy of New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
biggest point in this we have a process
that we use in terms of reviewing our
information and and our applications
when it comes to uh those associated
with an energy infrastructure project
there is no consistency and this is not
the fault of the administrator or the
chair or the vice chair who happens to
be my boss the um the commissioner of
Des it is that it is a flawly structured
organization
so I I would submit that no matter what
side of the issue you are and no matter
what you feel about what decisions have
been made or not if you want to see a
process that is predictable and
functioning you there needs to be some
reform
follow up please
follow up
um just um with regard to
um
time and the process in general have you
heard of the expression measure twice
cut once
sure thank you uh can I the inference
there is that I do not support an
accurate review of the of applications
and that is an incorrect that was not my
that was not my inference no debating
please the I want an accurate review of
all of it is that is the business Des is
in but a predictable functioning process
is produces the best outcomes
particularly in government
representative Doug Thomas has another
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question just for
clarification based on what you just
said
my understanding of what he's saying is
that none of the citing decision
timelines are being affected but because
the sac cannot meet because they can't
seem to get a quorum that the time
period is going past those established
timelines due to the fact that they
can't even meet is is that but is that
what I'm hearing yeah representative
that's exactly right it's the
functioning of it I do we are not
supporting the reduction in any amount
of review of any applications or
information we are we are advocating for
a review process that actually functions
because it is structured in a way that
it can meet it has a budget it has a
staff it can do follow-up compliancy and
it can work it has a staff that can work
with us back to my original point on the
things DS is responsible for to make
sure that as one of the previous
speakers talks about as much being done
concurrently as possible that requires
collaboration and organization and for
the whatever a process is done for the
uh the SEC portion of this there if
collaboration is happening between that
body and the other agencies that have a
responsibility it'll much more
effectively allow that concurrent
process versus a consecutive process
follow up thank you for the follow-up so
would
if if the SEC itself was retained but
modified either by number of
participants or who should be assigned
to the SEC so that they were able to
actually meet when they needed to would
that be a possible solution I definitely
and like I said I and and you know
commissioner Scott is always big on this
plus funding it and Staffing it you
nothing can happen if whatever body you
form doesn't have a staff and a budget
to do its work
thank you commissioner we appreciate you
being here to testify oh representative
closure has a question
uh thank you chair thank you
Sanborn uh on the public Import in this
legislation
is the public going to have enough say
the way this legislation is to have
their input on projects
so
um here's how I'll answer that I think I
think public input is essential to any
process involving the government so
we would not support anything that
eliminates the ability for the public to
have their voice be heard my
understanding is as written I think
there still retains a public process and
a public voice and again speaking
broadly per the uh parameters of the
chairman I my understanding based on
conversations of possible amendments is
it is very ways that could make that
even more clear and we would we would
certainly support any ability for the
public to have their voice be heard and
participate in the decision-making
process that does it in a way where
whatever you call the entity is able to
function is able to meet and has the
appropriate staff and budget to do its
work
the thank you commissioner
okay thank you
I guess there are further questions
representative Nutter has one
thank you Mr chairman um I just want
some clarification because I'm
remembering I think it was eight years
ago we had a bill to
allow less people on a certain committee
it might have been the SEC
um was it always nine members or does it
used to be more
I don't believe and I might be wrong
about this I don't believe the uh sense
constructed there's been a change in the
makeup of I don't think there's been an
SEC Reform Bill for at least since then
I I don't believe
I believe the current makeup is the
makeup it's been for
you know at least you know definitely
recent history
follow-up just a quick follow-up um
because I I just seem to remember
um how hard it is to get a quorum and
which I could relate to having run a
club Statewide and yep
that's exactly our point the current
makeup and again the folks appointed
have other jobs this is a secondary
responsibility and it is it is simply
extremely challenging for the SEC
administrator and the chair and the vice
chair to be able to have a time when
enough of them can meet for them to even
start doing this their business and and
that is our that is our biggest concern
is is is it is not structured and set up
in a way for it to effectively do its
business
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh there's a lot of
stuff built in New Hampshire that's not
necessarily an energy project I mean for
example I look to the former Rockingham
uh race track where there's this huge
Tuscan Village thing now I think it's
thousands and thousands of Acres of
development and they must have to get
all sorts of permits including Des Dot
and town boards and building committee
and so forth and so forth and so on do
any of those to the best of your
knowledge and something like that have a
public member or is the public allowed
to give input to them but the decision
is made by either appointed or elected
officials yes the the latter
representative and
um all of our agencies have the ability
when there's enough public interest to
have a public hearing and to get input
from the public some of them uh require
a public hearing some of our as you well
know our air permits uh public hearing
is required for as part of the process
but the decision is made based on state
and federal statutes by either appointed
or or
employees or elected officials
all right thank you commissioner I think
we're going to move on I appreciate your
being here this morning to give us
clarification on some of these issues
I'll next call on Barry Draper of new
Hampton
good morning Mr Draper three minutes
please
good morning I'm Barry Draper from New
Hampton New Hampshire which has almost
10 miles of really nice Scenic views and
natural environment along the
pemijwasset river and I just want to say
that I fought for eight and a half years
trying to prevent a scar running across
the whole state of New Hampshire and I
want to say that the SEC commission
really was a pain in the neck you are
absolutely right but they wanted to
protect the environment there was has
not been a single mention even from Des
of the environment we've talked money
money and streamlined to get that
development I want you to think I hope
many of you move to New Hampshire for
its natural beauty its Community the
people of New Hampshire want this
I want you to think streamlining and
money is not for the people I really
would like you to think about that and
table this I'm sorry about the
um whatever that uh the backup
um information that you've distributed
to a lot of people we aren't aware of
any of the good stuff that you've been
working on we should know about that
before you propose a bill
sorry about it I really would like to
know so I'll just leave I'll make it
quick because I know you've got a lot I
do have a lot of feeling for the things
that everybody has said today Des is an
absolutely important enough part of this
but even they have no they don't have
enough funding they don't have enough
people to back up what they have what
they're saying they're have to do they
can't back up what they you know they
don't they deny a permit and they can't
follow they don't go to any Court
sessions for any permits they haven't
got it we need to back and really think
about what we have here in New Hampshire
and save it thank you very much
thank you appreciate your perspective oh
did you have any questions I didn't mean
foreign
thank you
next we'll ask
Nancy martland to come up she said she
wants to read a statement from Laura
seifo I believe that might be
the name
good morning good morning I hope you can
do this in three minutes please I'm
gonna try hard
I I thank you for allowing me to read
this statement since I already had a
chance to testify the other day
this is from Lara sappho
45 Coventry Road Benton
is that better okay sorry Lara was the
Grafton County attorney during the
Northern Pass process and as such on the
vote of the Grafton County Commissioners
she represented the people of Grafton
County as interveners in the case
and I think it's important to note that
we keep referring to northern pass
because it's the main example that we're
all thinking about as something that
took a really long time
so this is Lara's statement
I'm submitting testimony in opposition
of hb609
it is hard for me to Fathom why
legislation is proposing to dissolve the
site evaluation committee a group
carefully crafted over years to ensure
that potential energy infrastructure
projects are carefully evaluated with
the needed expertise
the site evaluation committee is being
referred to as inefficient because this
group has taken the needed time required
by law to hear public testimony and
review proposed projects this is not
inefficiency it is the required
deliberation needed to ensure our
communities are not negatively
permanently impacted by enormous energy
infrastructure projects in the case of
northern pass the proposal presented to
the SEC was devastating to local
communities and New Hampshire citizens
for a plethora of reasons environmental
Financial Scenic economic historic just
to name a few
private land for miles would have been
impacted often without the permission of
the landowners The Proposal was vague
which accounted for some of the
challenges in efficiency
for Miles New Hampshire citizens front
yard this is the burial section
would be dug up with anything in the way
removed trees stonewalls septic systems
to make room for a permanent underground
concrete Corridor with significant
environmental issues the property
devaluation alone was significant and
devastating to the local citizens and
the towns and County government relying
on property taxes to fund services
the environmental impacts both
complicated
and raised enormous concern
necessitating significant expertise to
review properly
there has been talk of streamlining the
process
the review of unclear proposals to tear
up miles of New Hampshire land to build
permanent energy infrastructure Through
Rivers streams and private land cannot
be streamlined 30 seconds please it has
to be methodical and carefully reviewed
with needed expertise
When the Northern Pass proposal was
presented for evaluation I was stunned
and remained stunned
the site evaluation committee a group of
diverse citizens representing many
segments and types of expertise cannot
be disbanded for three people appointed
by the governor and approved by the
executive Council the site evaluation
committee is vital to protect New
Hampshire I urge you not to disband the
site evaluation committee
okay could you wrap this up please it's
wrapped I'm done
okay good thank you
any questions for Miss
Heartland
seeing none I thank you and I'd like to
call next on Kelly Weiser
of Campton
good morning and thank you good morning
thank you can you hear me okay
good morning Mr chairman and committee
members for the record my name is Kelly
Weiser from Campton and I represent
myself and my family today in order to
let you know how important it is for me
to be here today
um I'll tell you that my 15 year old
daughter who won the New Hampshire State
Alpine championships in skiing recently
is now currently representing New
Hampshire at the eastern regional
championships today and she's racing and
I was supposed to be there with her but
I've changed my plans to be here with
you today
um 12 years and one month ago I appeared
before the same committee when I I know
we're hearing it over and over again but
I think the point was made that Northern
Pass uh was proposed at that time and um
it is the I think the single uh most
obvious example of the inefficiencies of
the current uh system that exists for
utility sighting in New Hampshire I I
think we're all here for that reason
um that it is an incredibly inefficient
process and for my family it meant the
loss of our business Owls Nest Resort
and Golf Club in Camden and Thornton
after a very long protracted process
that ended really for me well I guess it
starts again here today but it ended
with me in front of the SEC in 2017
playing a very private recording I had
made of myself of one example of what it
was like for me personally to be
affected by by that SEC process so now
you've proposed legislation that
purports to upgrade this process and
your effort to do so would reduce
obviously with the amendment it appears
not completely eliminate the public
involvement in the process and I also
want to just highlight that an important
part of that is a representative of the
Attorney General's office
my family and I feel that you should be
seeking to streamline and modernize this
process and I think I'm feeling more and
more like this you want a new
information today we're talking a lot
about how the SEC is not potentially
properly funded or given the time the
the
appropriate
I think dedication of people to be able
to do the important job but I think
there's also another part to this and
it's about what is the burden on the
applicant what is that what is the
application process like for the
applicant of these types of projects in
New Hampshire during that whole entire
protracted Northern past period of time
my husband who's an attorney who works
on utility citing in Vermont saw several
projects come and and some of which he
was presenting on and and representing
the applicants and they were presented
because they met all the criteria that
was the thoughtful criteria that was put
in place for those projects
approved and and cited well Northern
Pass was still going on so I think that
um it's important that the process
includes the public but it all also be
public and I would say representative
Harrington asked about the testing
Tuscan Village project and public
involvement in that that's one project
in one town and when we're talking about
these large utility sighting projects
we're talking about something that
potentially affects the entire State of
New Hampshire which isn't just the
people but as some people have been
trying to say here it's also our sense
of place here in New Hampshire and so a
robust process that includes the public
is important for that so I would ask
that you uh either itl or retain this
bill for further consideration and I'll
take any questions if you have them
thank you very much and best of luck to
your daughter and her
competition this afternoon
seeing no questions I want to thank you
for taking the day off to come down here
and talk to us we appreciate your
perspective
I'll next call on Nick Krakoff of the
conservation law Foundation
good morning Mr Krakoff three minutes
please
um good morning chairman Vose and
honorable committee members my name is
Nick Krakow I'm with the conservation
law Foundation here in Concord
um I agree with chairman Vose and other
supporters of hb609 that improvements
could be made to the studying process
for energy facilities but due to several
concerns with the Bill I'm here today to
testify in opposition to hb609
the bill takes the wrong approach for
three main reasons first the POC lacks
the expertise and competence to decide a
number of the issues that are relevant
to citing decisions
the bill and the the HP 609 which
retains the current language and the law
um
makes it that in order to cite decisions
um the SEC must decide whether
the um the energy facility will not have
an unreasonable adverse effect on
Aesthetics historic sites air and water
quality the natural environment and
public health and safety
now the current SEC makeup with nine
members from across across a wide
spectrum of state agencies ensures that
the SEC possesses the necessary
competence and expertise for evaluating
the impacts caused by energy facilities
citing but investing the puc with sole
authority over setting decisions as
would occur under hb609 is the wrong
approach because the puc just doesn't
have the expertise to analyze impacts to
Aesthetics historic sites air and water
inequality National environment Etc
um you know what we've seen in recent
Decisions by the puc particularly on
Energy Efficiency that you know while
the POC is very has a lot of expertise
on rate payer impacts um when it comes
to other issues that they might consider
it just doesn't have that expertise
um so second HP 609 would unjust highly
weaken the public representation and
setting proceedings fortunately
um chairman Vose has mentioned that an
amendment May approve that I haven't
seen it yet that is encouraging but we
shouldn't eliminate those two public
members of the SEC committee from
setting decisions they're very important
and to provide a different perspective
um along that same line appropriately
eliminates specific requirements for the
sighting of high pressure gas pipelines
that there's a requirement under the
current law that the SEC adopts certain
rules that adopt more stringent
requirements for high gas high pressure
gas pipelines we saw in the Merrimack
Valley Massachusetts pipeline explosion
from a few years ago that gas pipelines
have significant safety and health
impacts so 30 seconds reducing those
requirements those extra requirements
for gas pipelines is just a mistake and
would have an unacceptable health and
safety risk for New Hampshire residents
so in conclusion I urge the committee to
either Vote itl or to retain the bill to
do these concerns that clf has with the
bill and thank you for your time and I'm
happy to answer any questions
thank you we appreciate you giving us
your perspective just for clarification
the high pressure gas line
information that you
mentioned in your testimony
was eliminated from RSA six the proposed
RSA 363 Colon D not because
it was determined that it's not an
important activity but because it's
already been done
the rules have already been written they
are in existing statute and the
amendment
has a has transitioned language in it
that says that existing SEC rules will
be enforced going forward so that that
issue is covered okay thank you for that
clarification I may address some of my
concerns okay questions for Mr Krakoff
uh representative McWilliams has a
question thank you chervos
um I'm interested in your experience
dealing with the puc would you say that
they are
an efficient body to take over what the
SEC needs to do in terms of being able
to get a quorum have meetings keep
things on schedule not go over 365 days
not really not the least um you know as
we saw with Energy Efficiency it took
them
over a year to decide that decision so
you know there there is you know
compelling evidence that the puc is not
overly efficient in their in their
processes
follow up
what follow-up
um and further um in terms of
transparency with the puc my
understanding is that with a
three-member board as proposed right now
for the SEC the puc being the
three-member board of the SEC would not
be able to ever meet without needing the
public present because even if two
members is a quorum that means that you
wouldn't have open meeting laws you
wouldn't be able to publish everything
that's that's determined and discussed
is that true yeah my understanding is
that
you know the um the exemption for the
right to no law requirements would apply
you know it applies to the puc and that
would carry over with this um with this
proposed Reform Bill and so those um
open meeting requirements would not
apply to the setting deliberations thank
you
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um thank you Mr Krakow for being here
um in your testimony you um said that
weakening of the citing requirements for
gas pipelines as would occur under 609
poses an unacceptable health and safety
risk to New Hampshire residents could
you please give me some examples of
health safety and environmental risks
that might not be considered going
forward with this proposed change sure
and I mean I just want to you know
mention again that chairman Bose has
stated that the current gas pipeline
requirement rules will you know be
maintained I haven't seen that Amendment
yet so I I don't know the extent to
which those will be retained But to
answer your question
um you know first off there's the major
environmental impacts of gas pipelines
um you know the increased carbon
emissions that come from gas pipelines
um but you know second
you know perhaps more importantly or not
not more importantly but important
nonetheless are there other health and
safety risks and you know we saw that
with the
um the Columbia gas pipeline explosions
and the Merrimack Valley of
Massachusetts back in 2018 where you
know some pipelines exploded and there
were houses that caught on fire and you
know one person died and
um you know set several you know met
many people are injured and so you know
there are significant health and safety
risks with with gas pipelines and
you know reducing the requirements for
those pipelines would pose an
unacceptable risk
thank you
so you know further questions I want to
thank you uh Mr Krakoff and call next on
Lisa Lino's from Lyman New Hampshire too
thank you very much her perspective
pardon I have handouts
I don't start the clock till you start
speaking
thank you
I'm sorry I do not I will email them if
that's okay
okay now comes the hard part
you have to get through all your
testimony in three minutes please I'll
do my best Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to speak to you today my name is Lisa
lenos I'm a resident of the State of New
Hampshire and I've participated in at
least 10 separate dockets before the
site evaluation committee very familiar
with the process I'm going to begin by
saying outright I went through hb609
both the amended version which I know
has not been voted on as well as
introduct introduced version and
compared it to 162h at the outset the
bill as written has an agenda in mind
and you need to understand that agenda
there are changes in the SEC process
under the bill that are subtle and
likely to go unnoticed but they are
contrary to the transparent and open
process we share today the bill includes
errors and omissions creates confusion
as to who's in charge introduces
conceptual changes to the SEC process
that weaken its Effectiveness harm the
public and potentially create serious
risk for the State of New Hampshire the
table that is at the top of what I sent
out to you is my side by side with is
where I highlight all of the issues that
I found with the bill I guarantee you I
missed a bunch of them because this bill
is very subtle the way it changes the
process and people need you need a good
lawyer who is not biased reviewing this
bill for you before I go into some of
those though I was very upset when I
watched the hearing last week and
listened to the the
justifications for why this bill is a
very good bill and why it should be
um support it and I'm going to go
through a couple of those because I
think that's more important right now if
you're going to vote on the basis of
those justifications you need to
understand the truth of what was being
said last week
first you were told
um
that this bill is the Senate Bill 256
Senate report
committee report it is not that bill
this bill is if you if you look at exam
exhibit three of my handout
that is a a portion of the SB 256 report
the five member committee that included
three sponsors of hb609 voted to support
the 10 recommendations that are on the
last page of that handout six of those
10 recommendations were discarded
outright hb609 barely resembles the
result of SB 256 please understand that
it is not that report you were told that
time is money and the longer it takes
for an application to move through the
SEC process the higher costs for
consumers thoughts time may be money but
the cost of building Merchant
infrastructure in New England has no
impact on Energy prices we are a
deregulated state or a deregulated
region our utilities do not build our
own power plants and New Hampshire
generally does not mandate long-term
contracts for energy projects our Energy
prices are market-based and set
competitively according to supply and
demand if a project costs 60 million 100
million or one billion dollars it is
completely irrelevant and is not borne
by the rate payers and if they do not
change market price you were told that
the public in the process will have the
same level of participation as it has
today that's not true and I I can I
highlight that in my report in my table
and I I hope to be able to talk to some
of those New Hampshire citing process is
that you were told that the New
Hampshire citing process is too onerous
and developers are not coming to New
Hampshire New Hampshire's citing process
is no more onerous than other states
with similar adversarial processes
exhibit one in my package shows about
half the states in the country have
statewide energy siding boards just like
the site evaluation committee
look at Connecticut Rhode Island
Massachusetts Vermont all of them there
are other considerations that are
driving developers elsewhere we have
limited land difficult terrain highly
sensitive environmental habitat concerns
shortened construction seasons and
outside of issues such as the fact that
the federal tax policies that supports
subsidies for renewable energy has been
in flux for the last eight years
you were told each people 609 will drive
federal dollars to the state if you look
at exhibit four you can see that is a
document from the White House that
explains what the funds that will be
from the infrastructure Bill be to New
Hampshire there's nothing that looks
like it relates to an SEC citing process
finally you're told that hb609 will
solve in New Hampshire's NIMBY problem
first of all we don't have a NIMBY
problem but anyway if it does it will be
it will be because the language of
hb609 does something that no citing law
should do
it places the legislature's thumb on the
scale of promoting the approval of
energy projects all over all other
issues including the environment and if
I only probably have only a second to
talk to you I want to highlight why that
is if you look at the table that I
handed out that first item RSA 306 D1
and then the second one D2 as well as
um d11 I believe
that that what that does d11
D1 the Preamble of the bill says adds
the ins inserts the tax
to support the construction of critical
infrastructure be encouraged 36. in this
whole area a bill where it's telling you
how the SEC has to take care to be
concerned about the environment public
health and safety it goes in and says oh
but we want to encourage critical
infrastructure
that is bias not only that it never
defines what critical infrastructure is
big mistake because it could be anything
do you think a win project that produces
thirty percent of the time is critical
infrastructure no
then if you look at 11 it reasserts it
reasserts that point there are many
other issues with the bill that fall
just like that I encourage you to itl
this Bill thank you
thank you questions for MS lenoze
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question looking through some
of the exhibits you have here on exhibit
one and thank you for listening out the
states what they do I was looking at the
other New England states and I noticed
that uh all of them except for Vermont
uses a puc to make the site decisions
but the rest of states in New England
all use a uh a distinguished site
Council or board
um so and we heard from the
Environmental Services saying that it'd
be they'd be in favor of anything as
long as there was a group or Council
that actually would be able to get
together so my pertaining of this bill
and what I want to hear is is would it
make it better if there was actually a
group or Council that actually was
effective it could show up would have
funding and members to be available yes
I believe a professionalized group of
people that is dedicated but one of the
issues that the state of New Hampshire
is wrestled with over and over again is
contrary to what Mr Sanborn said they're
only as far as I can tell two open cases
before the Senate evaluation committee
not cousins I don't know where that
number came from so it's hard to keep
that group of people busy if it's
there's not that much in the way of
activity so that that's one of the
reasons why we're
why we're using people from different
parts of the state to do this work
follow-up
and so in that case in your estimation
how would you propose for it be able to
make it more efficient for a group to be
able to do this I don't think the issue
is efficiency I think the SEC process
works very well it could be tweaked
there's no question it could be tweaked
okay
um I included the I want an exhibit
that's in there that I didn't get to
talk to is Peter wrote's testimony Peter
wrote to his counseling for the public
for many years on Northern Pass Antrim
win and others and he addresses a
question of efficiency and one of the
biggest issues it has it was covered as
a recommendation in the SB 256 report is
that the application process is a
problem in the state the developers come
to the State SEC process and their
applications are not complete then they
refuse to answer questions on those
issues they change the process the
application in the process and it draws
drags this whole thing down we heard
some testimony about that in northern
pass that needs to be fixed I don't know
why there was no adjustment to it in as
609 but for whatever reason and that and
it encourages that be done that the
applicants as was stated for the puc in
Vermont be held to a standard and not
play around with that application thank
you
just so that we can get clarification
and cl and be clear on the number of
applications before the site evaluation
committee may I ask the site evaluation
committee administrator Mr Beamer to
give us a quick overview of how many
applications are pending before the site
evaluation committee
and uh permits there are zero permits
for New Generation facilities a lot of
what we consider we sort of throw into
the site evaluation committee are ones
that may have been announced or once it
may have are trying to get support or
ones that are theoretical but there are
zero actual tangible projects before the
site valuation committee right now the
two issues that um Miss lenos accurately
referenced are both investigation of
complaints against the existing wind
farms
thank you for that clarification
investigations against existing wind
farms over to the Department of energy
and I would be in charge of permitting
the new generation in whatever sort of
structure you you decide to implement
okay thank you for that clarification
for those listening at home who may not
been have been able to hear Mr Beamer's
comments he said there are no currently
active permitting applications in front
of the SEC and two ongoing
certificate complaint issues before the
SEC representative McWilliams asked
question thank you Mr chair
um so looking at the information that
you provided here just
guide me through this are you are you
making a recommendation that the
revamping of the New Hampshire SEC
increased the number of megawatts that
the threshold is for the SEC review are
you recommending that there shall be
public counsel for each applicant can
you just walk me through the
recommendations based on this do you
want me to go down this list your
recommendations
well certainly in terms of the um
I do strongly believe that this the
megawatt threshold should be raised to
100 or 125 megawatts the sp256 committee
agreed with that voted on that as did
the three including the three sponsors
of 609 that will take off the off the
plate of the SEC small projects that it
you know Antrim win was 28.8 megawatts
it was under 30 megawatts
it didn't even be long before the site
evaluation committee but in any event it
was petitioned to go there
um and it took forever to do if it had
been handled by the local authorities
planning board it would have been dealt
with much more efficiently and it
wouldn't have wasted the state's time so
I I that and that I think that goes for
any projects Massachusetts has 100
megawatt threshold in terms of public
counsel
okay this is a very important point I
don't want to repeat what other people
have said but Peter wrote's own words in
his testimony state that the only voice
that is representing the public but for
those who are who chose to intervene
themselves is Peter Roth or this public
counsel and he's representing the public
from a legal perspective Department of
energy is not take they don't have the
same level of obligation that a lawyer
from department of justice has he's not
they're not representing the public in
fact according to the bill they're
representing an encouraging critical
energy infrastructure to be built above
and beyond everything else so I do
firmly believe that concept of the
public needs to be a mandated
view a mandated part of this process and
um and actually according to Peter
wrote's own testimony there is political
pressure on occasion very rare but it
has happened and he had suggested that
that role be put under the consumer
advocate office or somewhere out
somewhere where it may be doe as well he
does say that just so that they could
act independently and allow to do their
job without political pressure
thank you
okay so you know further questions for
Miss Lanos thank you very much for being
here oh representative Brown has a
question sorry I hadn't put my hand up
because I saw so many others up earlier
thank you Mr chair
um
once again give me a little bit of
leeway to be idealistic here again it
seems like I'm doing that all the time
um I'm hearing from a number of people
that are up here
that there's some kind of an insinuation
that the some evil plot coming from this
committee
and when you st and and
when you started off and and I'm asking
you
just because you're sitting there and
you mentioned it and this would apply to
anyone else when you first sat down you
said you think there's an agenda
and and then you move on and I'm hearing
this from other people tell me what that
you think that agenda is number one and
then if the chairs
will help me out as a freshman here for
any of you if you think that there's a
some kind of a process here where
someone is doing something
illicit or against their against their
oath to this legislature there is an
Ethics Committee to which you can take
that complaint
and and they will follow up on that with
this legislature I I I'm I'm
disheartened to think that having come
here in my first year that everyone in
this room believes that people of this
legislature are against them in some way
so my question specifically thank you Mr
chair for the time what do you think the
agenda is here I'd like to know what
you're saying this agenda is that's a uh
that's coming from this I guess that you
meant the committee but maybe it's a
broader thing than that so thank you I'm
not I'm not tagging you personally you
understand that but I'm interested to
know thank you
I apologize in the the word the use of
the word agenda was not intended to
suggest that there was any anything
unethical that is happening here or that
anyone is acting inappropriately the
agenda meant that the the the bill as it
is structured and it's very important
that people see this there is an effort
to move not take authority away from the
state agencies but it moves Authority
significant authority to the state
agencies and when that happens
then we get into this administrative
World versus a public process world
and I'm if I may I'd like to give you an
example of where that is happening or
where I think it's problematic
um in under the bill 609 it states that
um
that it's uh hold on a second that the
doe will administratively approve
changes to the facility ownership or
transfers of the certificate
administratively
currently under RSA 162h 16 which is the
findings part of the existing bill
the applicant the SEC goes to a fully
adjudicative process and then determines
as part of its findings whether or not
the applicant has the the managerial
Technical and financial ability to
construct and operate in accordance with
the terms of the certificate
adjudicative process now someone comes
in chooses to buy that facility from the
current owner
there is no such obligation that that
happened anymore
and we know that facilities their owners
go bankrupt AES Londonderry went
bankrupt we know stored solar which is
not affecting any certificates for the
that the SEC had issued but stored
solely that owns our biomass facilities
went bankrupt we and it is a hassle if
anything and we would be it would be a
bad situation for the state to not why
would we move that level of scrutiny but
that's what the bill does because it's
handing authority over to this to the
agencies the public is not involved in
that process anymore that's then that
and I think there are a number of other
similar kinds of things happening where
it there's attempt to puc does the
decision making the doe does the other
stuff and the other stuff is outside
public purview by and large and that's
the agenda I'm talking about and it's so
subtle in the way the bill is written
there's another example with regard to
um
significant changes sizable changes in
additions to the project according to
the bill the way it's written and I
would love to be corrected on this
it basically says that they only have to
submit an application to the commission
and the commission need only approve it
it doesn't say they have to get a new
certificate for it which means that the
granite reliable project with 30 99
megawatt project and 400 foot turbines
can be replaced with 650 foot turbines
become a 300 megawatt project with a
simple majority vote in a public meeting
of the commission
that is not appropriate and that appears
to be how 609 is written and that that
settles that subtle agenda means we're
taking away from the public process and
we're giving it to the administrative
process and our voices are lost in the
in doing so so I apologize I am not
pointing fingers at anyone being evil or
unethical
follow up follow up I Just Want to Thank
You Mr chairman for allowing me that and
thank you for your response I appreciate
it thank you
representative Doug Thomas has a
question
thank you Mr chairman um if I made for
clarification
um on the current Amendment uh I know we
don't have the revised one here back yet
from OLS but on the current Amendment on
page four
um line 30 actually line 28 it starts
off by saying that the department shall
administratively approve changes of
ownership and transfers of certificates
within 90 days of a petition if it
determines the new certificate holder
has adequate Financial Technical and
managerial managerial capability to
assure construction and operation of the
facility and continuing compliance with
the terms and conditions of the
certificate can you
give me your interpretation of that
well if it were good
hang on Mr Blue knows what's your point
of order
um yeah my point of order is we seem to
have clearly
gone into the area of discussing a
specific
text of an amendment that we may have
seen and I'm just seeing on my screen
moments ago but certainly the witness
who's being asked to comment on it
doesn't have it in front of her and and
I'm not I don't think that's fair thank
you for that point of order the witness
brought up this issue and so it's
legitimate to ask her to explain what
she meant by that issue
under the current law 162-h it is
required that the the applicant or the
new owner go through a an adjudicative
process which means cross-examination
and Expo you know presentation of all
the information including confidential
information in a non-public session that
be made available so it is a much more
open process I would argue that the SEC
doesn't have rules I'm not sure what
rules they use for determining whether
the applicant meets managerial
managerial Technical and financial but
in any event it is a public process
everyone is involved everyone is a
opportunity to say what's going on and
in
the bill at the suggestion amendment is
saying it's very closed door we'll just
sit in a room with the applicant he
could tell us what we think what do you
think show us the information and we'll
make it we as the doe will make a
determination
I think the more public process involved
in pressure on the applicant the more
likely we will get a better outcome
I think there's risk otherwise
okay representative Christian has a
question
thank you Tara thank you Ms Lidos for
taking my question and for your
fantastic testimony
um I really appreciated that you
provided us with the recommendations
from um gosh the SB 256 commission
um can you speak a little bit more to
the items that were on there that you
feel were not adequately addressed in
hb609
yes absolutely
um the first one obviously is 609 that
you know move the adjudicative process
moved to the puc the second one raised
the statutory limit which I had
mentioned I think that's a is a very
important process the third one disallow
developer petition petitions for
projects less than 100 megawatts what
that means is that under the current law
and under the law is written the
applicant under the 609 the applicant
has the ability to petition the puc or
the site sec
to assert jurisdiction on if it's on its
project even if it doesn't meet the 30
megawatt threshold today or what will be
100 megawatt threshold and what that is
encouraged in the past and does today is
um is shopping Forum Shopping if they
don't like what if they perceive
opposition within the local community
they go to the state and know they'll
get a more favorable View and review and
that is also mentioned in Peter Rhodes
testimony from 2021
require the puc to develop rules on how
to adjudicate the application process
that is key that that is right now the
application goes to the chair or the the
committee the committee can make a
determination in non-public it really is
up to the the chair to do that as to
whether or not it meets the requirements
uh or or there's sufficient information
for it for the SEC to proceed
in one case that happened there was a
win project proposed in near Newfound
Lake the applicant did not have control
over all the land where he was going to
build his project particularly the
transmission line submitted the
application nonetheless with no
certainty that he had control over that
land in that case the chair denied the
completion of the application because
that was not there and and the app can
end up not building but Groton when the
applicant did not have a full
transmission line developed the
application went through and it was
delayed the process was delayed because
of that so the application needs to
process needs to be improved
tremendously
there's not much to say about the role
the administrator but for the fact that
under current under current
SEC rules or decisions
the there is a an order on the record
with the SEC that grants the
administrator full authority to make
decisions that are unappealable and now
I know this is getting into details but
there was a problem with that and that
is something that needs to be resolved
unfortunately I don't know in a sense it
has been discarded because under 609
because 609 gives
Department of energy the authorities
that was re-referencing too so that's
that doesn't really come out too much
now clarify the role of state agencies I
think I think they're
I think that to some extent 609 is doing
that and to some extent it's not
I'm sorry
did someone say something
oh okay
um continue please
I can explore the department of energy
investigating a certificate compliance I
think that's what 609 is really trained
to do because it's gonna there is a
there is an ongoing issue with
enforcement under the site evaluation
committee unfortunately I don't think
the 609 resolves that provide rules
about the application process within
State agencies the other three uh on the
last one actually number nine I think is
extremely important I'm really really
don't know why it was not put into 609
and that is SEC itself has asked members
of the public when we have when we have
been forced to pay the fees we're
considerably lower than what they are
today
um they said unfortunately because the
fees are hard-coded in the statute we
have no authority to waive them or
administratively lower them on a
case-by-case basis that was a
recommendation that be put into six or
whatever ultimately will be the bill and
it wasn't so that I think no matter what
that should be put into the bill
so thank you
see no further questions for Ms lenoze I
will next call on oh representative
Wendy Thomas has a question thank you Mr
chair
um
you're you're pointing out the wording
in the bill for critical infrastructure
um is is interesting thank you for doing
that
um and I also see in exhibit four you
gave us the infrastructure investment
and jobs act information on what it
covers I have also heard the the term
critical infants infrastructure used
with regard to this bill and what it
will cover
is one of your concerns that
the state of New Hampshire may use some
of this money for some Pipelines
no I no it is my what I'm this money in
the way it's outlined towards how it
will be allocated in the state of New
Hampshire I don't know ultimately what
control the state will have over that
but what I was pointing out is there's
nothing in here that looks like a that
that involves say the construction of
um generate energy generated generating
facilities or even transmission per se
um so I was like if if money's if we're
if the site evaluation process is
holding up money coming into the state
because we have a messed up SEC process
I don't that's not really representative
of the kind of kinds of things the money
would
go towards okay thank you
okay seeing no further questions for Ms
lenoza I'll next call on Lori Lerner to
give us her perspective on this
legislation
Mr chair if it's helpful I can email all
my documents
it's okay thank you
well Ms uh Lerner is passing out her
testimony I'll point out to committee
members that I just forwarded you
email a few minutes ago
that provides
amendment number
2023-0931h which I just received from
ask OLS so
Ms learner you know our you now are on
the clock and you have three minutes
good morning my name is Laurie Lerner
I'm from Bridgewater New Hampshire and I
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
this bill today I am strongly opposed to
hb609 I have been involved in the SEC
process since 2012. as a participant and
an observer of many different dockets
I'm not going to go through each one I
also participated in the SEC rulemaking
effort
that all was around the time sb99 was
introduced and enacted as a Statewide
effort which included a significant
amount of public participation to fix a
process that had no public Trust
I also have participated in the hb2 and
SB 256 study committees chairman votes a
statement of nearly unanimous support
for hb609 could be looked at another way
none of the members of the public
supported the HB 609 approach during
those study committees those who
supported this approach were agency
staff representatives from the utilities
and others with a vested interest in
getting energy projects permitted
quickly and easily
Senator Ruth Ward's opposition to this
bill should also send a strong message
given her role as the chair for the SEC
reform study group
the problem is not with the SEC process
aside from two unrelated intended
consequences which Lisa lanaus had
mentioned regarding the
SEC administrator Authority as well as
the cost if you have any challenge to
that
the problem with the SEC is that it
consists of a panel of decision makers
who have little to no relevant knowledge
of the important subject material before
them the SEC committee members including
the puc Commissioners change frequently
which results in no long-term
institutional knowledge of the complex
and technical issues involved with the
citing and enforcement of large energy
facilities
case in point the current slate of
appointed puc Commissioners have the
following term expirations commissioner
Simpson July 2023 chairman goldner July
2025 commissioner Chata paddai July
2027. how will HB 609 provide any
institutional knowledge benefit when
there's a revolving door of only three
commissioners
considered decision makers on a
staggered six-year terms the puc
Commissioners will barely come up to
speed before the term expires given
their lack of energy citing background
initially and the variety of energy
sources likely to require citing review
during their tenure
I would encourage all St members to read
the transcript from the March 9th 2022
Antrim win docket
2021-02 public meeting
for some reason uh the meetings have
become public meetings instead of
hearings but that's another story to
more I'd effectively understand the
multitude of concerns with the puc
taking on the SEC adjudicative effort
the purpose of the meeting was to review
and vote on a subcommittee
recommendation the concerns include
number one a member of the public being
told by the SEC puc to submit written
comments after the meeting even though
the vote was occurring during the
meeting
SEC puc member who expressed lack of
understanding wanted to ask question on
testimony of a public member but was
told to wait until the end the SEC puc
chair then moved to vote before the
question could be asked in the interest
of time the SEC puc chair moved for a
vote without any deliberation just
allowing a question which did not even
get answered chairman Vose had attended
this public meeting and expressed his
concern and frustration with the process
these actions lead to frustration from
the public who are acutely aware of
complexity and consequences of their
ill-informed decisions in addition to
concerns with the puc taking the
adjudicative component of the SEC the
separation of duties of the SEC between
doe and POC will only serve to increase
the level of distrust and frustration by
the public regardless of how the
membership is constructed the public
needs confidence that the SEC decision
makers are unbiased experts in the areas
for which they are making these critical
decisions that will not be the case if
SB if hb609 were to move forward please
vote to itl hb609 thank you very much
I'd be happy to take any questions thank
you questions for Ms Lerner
thank you I want to thank you for being
here next I'll call on Catherine corkery
Mr chair the New Hampshire Sierra Club
Mr chair could I ask a point of
clarification certainly
um regarding the uh amendment that you
just uh delivered to us
um I noticed that the financial note is
still missing do you know if there's a
valid Financial note for this amendment
yet uh you could check with the house
clerk fine Financial notes are filed
with the house clerk so if there is one
it'll be there okay thank you thank you
Miss corkery
three minutes please thank you
my name is Catherine corkery I'm from
New Hampshire Sierra Club and
um we represent 15 000 people in New
Hampshire and we oppose this bill
there I appreciate all of the comments
so far
um and especially the fiscal note
question that was one that I had and I
had called the clerk's office earlier
asking about the procedure the schedule
of this bill because it was after
the the fast track bills that go to and
I they told me that there was no fiscal
note so
um I perhaps there will be one
with
with the amendment or
um maybe that'll be done in the Senate
I don't know
um but that is a a big question of mine
because this involves
um every everything that we've heard
from the uh the different
um agencies is that there will be more
people more people to do this work and
um I'm not sure where those that funding
will come from
um today I just wanted to highlight
um
page six of the amended version that
hasn't been introduced to this committee
um page six uh talks about the timelines
um and specifically uh page or line 16
it says that within 30
365 days the acceptance of the
application the commission shall issue
or deny
and then
it says if the commission at any time
while an application
for a certificate is before it deems it
to be in the public interest it may
temporarily suspend deliberations and
time frames established under this
section not to exceed 90 days any
further suspension shall be subject to
the consent of the applicant
and this all the time the
petitions or permits at the other
offices at the other agencies are going
on at the same time you know I think
about
um people spinning dishes you know like
we've got these dishes spinning over
here for Des and these dishes spinning
over there for D.O.T crossing streets
and what have you planning Commissions
in in other in the towns being affected
um and it all has to come within 365
days
um alteration of terrain permits take a
long time they it and to have all of
this done at the same time
we did not see that and we do not see
that as we heard from uh previous
speakers
often the the application is incomplete
or there are changes
at while we're moving so those 30
seconds spinning 30 seconds please and
asking that this all comes to a dead
stop and 365 days
with maybe 90 more I think is a mistake
you're setting up expectations that will
not be met
and
um given the time constraints that's
what I will limit myself to thank you
thank you we appreciate you giving us
your perspective
questions for Miss corkery
seeing none I'll move on next to Karen
Payne of Effingham New Hampshire
good morning Miss Payne
good morning you have three minutes
thank you yes thank you I suspect a long
hearing so thank you everybody who's
come and listened earnestly
um I do believe there's a corporate
agenda here
maybe there's not
um I would settled my mind if there was
an application fee for foreign power
that was
somewhere around eighteen hundred
dollars a megawatt
um I would feel a little bit better but
um and I was also thrilled to hear
people speak that the SEC head process
has worked well for them
when I sat here last week the first time
I heard about the SEC and how they're
part-time and have too many
responsibilities I thought to myself uh
oh that's a good point
um what about that but then now that
I've heard those same lines about four
times you could even put a actual person
from the SEC up here in front of the
microphone it's I'm suspicious it's lost
its credibility those lines have
filtered down from somewhere and people
keep repeating the same lines so at this
point when I hear that it makes me more
suspicious
I fear that this
um Bill what is well timed to leave this
committee and reach our current Senate
so I don't I don't deeply know how the
legislative process works but I ask this
committee that if this bill leaves this
committee
that it please
um that you please take into
consideration all these things that we
who are opposed to the bill have been
speaking about because once it leaves
this committee even if it leaves opposed
from what I understand
um
it could it could have a different story
when it reaches the Senate
um
so I'm my background is I'm a
schoolteacher I spend my life teaching
people how to think I hope I have
graduated a lot of free thinkers that
will use a very strong decision-making
process
decisions can be done short term I feel
that's what 609 is doing uh yes it will
get corporate money from New Hampshire
with our dependability if it passes but
is this not a rich process the group of
us together
bringing up different ideas and perhaps
some we've heard some new things that
could be more Progressive in going
forward for the state
um I wish 30 seconds decision is made
long term and that we realize there are
things that cannot be bought once cut
old growth forests cannot be bought once
blasted Granite Vistas cannot be bought
our physical health our mental health
comes from New Hampshire sanctuaries
from the silent power of our Wilderness
we all know that Health cannot be bought
thank you thank you appreciate you being
here and sharing your perspective and
we're going to wrap up this morning with
our last speaker Mr Matt Leahy from the
forest Society Mr Leahy 32nd I mean uh
three minutes please
I will do it in one minute Mr chairman
um so I just wanted I know there's been
a lot of talk and I'm Matt Leahy public
policy director for the four Society I
did testify last week and I did hand out
written testimony just for the record
but I did I know there's been a lot of
talk that the SEC is broken and I just
wanted to point out one
example where I just would disagree with
that so back in 2019 Chinook solar
proposed a 30 megawatt solar project out
in Fitzwilliam
SEC began that process July 2019 it made
its approval decision in October 2020
um and and
yes that's more than 365 days but it's
you know 15 or 16 months um
and part of that SEC process occurred
during covid when all the covid
disruptions so
um I so yes there could be some
improvements made to the existing SEC
process but
I think there certainly are examples
where the SEC has
acted relatively quickly to make
important citing decisions on renewable
energy especially so I just wanted to
make the committee aware of that
I'll take any questions
thank you for your perspective
representative Christian has a question
ah thank you chair thank you for taking
my question and
um I'm not really sure that you're the
perfect person to address this too but
um given
you're saying that you think that the
SEC process actually works well do you
think that could be an explanation for
why we haven't heard any testimony from
developers who want to develop but
apparently are are being stymied by this
process yeah that's a good question and
I just would say one thing the four
Society did not engage at all in that
solar project on Fitzwilliam I just
um so I don't have any details about
that I'm not sure I can accurately
answer you know why developers you know
do or do not bring a project forward but
it's it is a good question and it would
be interesting to hear directly from
developers though
thank you
okay seeing no further questions I want
to thank you for
giving us additional testimony
Mr Beamer do you would you like to say
something to the committee before we
move on
does anybody have a question for the
site evaluation committee administrator
seeing none
thank you very much I appreciate you
being here I know you have uh have to
leave because you have another
appointment
so I have no more pink cards so with
that I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 609
and it is now
1106 I guess so 1104 1105.
so we will open a public hearing on or
resume the public hearing on House Bill
142.
and at the conclusion of that public
hearing we'll take a break for lunch
and then when we come back from lunch
we'll have our executive session on the
five remaining bills
for us so can we begin our uh
history 142 testimony uh yes
representative Gorman thank you uh we
haven't gotten the numbers on the blue
sheet and online for this particular
bill for 609. okay representative
pleasure will
get to work on acquiring those numbers
and we will report the numbers on both
bills at the end of the 142 public
hearing
so
first step for HP 142 is Kristen coach
or Koch from the business and industry
Association
okay Miss coach says she has written
testimony that she will submit instead
of testifying so
we'll thank her for that and move along
and ask Meredith Hatfield from the
nature conservatacy to give her
perspective on HB 142
thank you good morning chairman Vos Vice
chairman Thomas and members of the
committee Meredith Hatfield for the
nature conservancy and I wanted to start
off by saying that I will be speaking
both to the original version of the bill
as well as to the amendment that
chairman Bose brought forward
and I also wanted to start by thanking
chairman Vos
um for bringing forward an amendment to
try
to resolve this long-standing issue and
as he knows I'm quite familiar with the
history but I thought his very concise
description and overview was extremely
helpful last week The Nature Conservancy
supports a rapid transition
to clean our local more sustainable
energy sources and we are a large
landowner an easement holder and a
steward of lands around the state that
we manage for a range of values
including sustainable Agriculture and
Forestry among many others and we
understand deeply and work hard to
ensure that New Hampshire has healthy
sustainable forests we are also keenly
aware of the many economic challenges
that Northern
in rural parts of our state face
especially in koas County which is home
to some of our state's richest and most
beautiful
natural resources but as you know
struggles to enjoy the economic
successes of other parts of our state
and we at the at the nature conservancy
we know that the wood-based economy of
our state is really important to the
health of the North country and we are
particularly supportive of modern wood
Heat Technologies and those which
efficiently
help us take advantage of sustainably
harvested wood
with respect to the original Bill House
Bill 142 as you heard last week
unfortunately the PPA at issue in this
bill has already resulted in
approximately 150 million dollars
in over-market costs that are paid
through the stranded cost recovery
charge by eversource customers and we
think that at this time it's not a
prudent use of our very limited
resources
particularly at a time when people are
struggling with with such high energy
bills and when you have several bills
before you looking at ways to protect
customers and reduce energy costs
the original Bill does not provide
sufficient guidance to the puc regarding
reforming the PPA to stop the
ever-increasing over-market cerantic
costs by requiring
that the puc approve any and all relief
for the plants without any parameters on
cost and it doesn't include sufficient
direction to ever Source regarding steps
it could take to manage the contract
differently to reduce those stranded
costs
and we think the legislature should
instead ensure that incentives for clean
energy are available to all clean
Technologies in ways that reduce cost
and provide broader benefits
with respect to the amendment
um
I want to thank chairman Vos for taking
a different approach because the current
one hasn't been working
but want to draw attention to the
language that would forgive 50 million
of the 150 million in over Market costs
we don't support that forgiveness we do
understand
the economic realities that the plant is
facing but we would Advocate and
respectfully request that you simply add
the 50 million to the 100 million dollar
balance
that the plant is carrying so that rate
payers at least have a chance someday in
the future to recover those funds
we also believe that the amendment
should require that the puc open a
docket to address these issues
and that it should provide clear
direction to the puc and to eversource
so that if ever source is required to
continue to sell the output from the
plant that it be required to do so in a
way that reduces cost to rate payers and
reduces those over-market stranded costs
one approach could be to change the
requirement that eversource resell the
power and instead use it for default
service I don't know if that would work
but it seems that every option should be
on the table particularly when prices
are so high
and rate payers are having to pay
stranded costs because of the price
differential between the PPA and the
market costs that eversource receives
and I think that that that approach in a
new docket could also
help inform future ppas that the state
might entertain with new clean energy
resources thank you
thank you I appreciate your perspective
on this legislation do we have questions
for Ms Hatfield
seeing none I'll thank you again and ask
Mr Tom friends of the New Hampshire
Department of energy to give us his
perspective
once again thank you
good morning chairman Vose and members
of stne thank you for the opportunity to
testify this morning on the amendment to
HB 142 as you know the department of
energy opposed the original Bill we are
neutral on this one but we think it's a
tremendous improvement over the original
hb142 we do want to point out that this
won't solve all the issues
the cumulative reduction factors is
still there
markets will be what they are and if
they revert back to the types of pricing
we saw in the markets previously the CRF
will increase and we will
probably back to where we were years ago
with the number going above the 100
million dollars
that said we are happy to work with
with you and others uh going forward and
I'm happy to take any questions you have
okay thank you representative Doug
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
um considering uh Miss Hatfield's
previous suggestion and her testimony uh
how do you feel about those suggestions
if they're viable or not and should we
even go forward with them
it used to be used the the purchase of
purchases 500 000 megawatt hours of
energy previously it was used when the
company was vertically integrated as
part of its portfolio
after divestiture as you know it's
basically a almost simultaneous Buy sell
into the market are there ways to
minimize that certainly but with those
ways come additional risks either to the
company or uh
potentially to rate payers so
it takes two to change this contract
I think you can ask the puc to open up a
docket and look at it but obviously this
is a contract that would need to be
agreed to for any changes by both
eversource and by by Burgess I've looked
at other ways to minimize this looking
at forward strips
a three-year five-year unpeak off-peak
strips
and
it may reduce that amount by having
higher values sold in at on Peak periods
but quite honestly the prices when I
looked at them really weren't that high
uh
so and those prices could change
we'd work with parties if they're
amendable to that but uh
you know I think we're fine with where
we are right now and going back to the
100 million like I said we're fairly
neutral on this and we think it's a
tremendous improvement over the original
hb142
I don't think there are any silver
bullets out there representative
representative Kelly has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr friends
for being here I'd just like to say
first of all thank you for the I was
reading the original PPA from 2011 and
seeing your name listed there I'd like
to thank you for your many years of
service to the state
um my question is how um we had we heard
the um the the floating of of using it
for the default service right how much
uh what is the capacity required by
eversource for the default service ah
good question uh eversources total
retail sales in a year about 7.6 to 7.8
million megawatt hours uh they're re
their default Service solicitations uh
broken out between
cni and and residential customers is
somewhere in the 4 million megawatt hour
range and the purchase of this is 500
000 megawatt hours so
uh you know it's a little over 10
percent
we're a little under 10 so thank you
depends on the year but in that range
it's it's not an insignificant number
but it's also not a you know it's not a
majority of the purchase either
well seeing no further questions I want
to thank you for uh stopping by this
morning and giving us your perspective
my pleasure thank you representative
okay
next I'll ask Jason stock to come up and
give us his perspective on this
legislative proposed legislation
good morning Mr stock
well good morning uh for the record I'm
Jason stock I'm the executive director
of the New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association
and I'm happy to come here and speak in
in support of the bill and in support of
the amendment
and really in support of the the effort
to keep this important Market going uh
I've testified before you before on
House Bill 165 166 and gave you a lot of
information about the state's Timberland
the state's Forest products industry
um and why low-grade wood markets are a
very important part of that fabric
and so I won't out of respect for your
time I won't get into all the details
and nuances of trees and Forestry
although I'd love to but I won't this
morning but I just want to hit a couple
high points and then I'd be happy to
answer questions
um
you know in and again by way of
background for some of the new folks
here uh just a couple quick points on
who nhtoa is where landowners enforce
products industry our Members Own and or
manage about a million Acres of the
state's Timberland
um the industry that this land base
supports is about a 2.5 billion dollar a
year industry and includes Sawmills
power plants even some wood that's taken
and used and chipped for paper making in
in Maine as well as in Eastern New York
um and you know this this power plant as
you heard earlier represents Burgess
biopower represents about two 750
000 tons of biomass or low-grade wood a
year that's a huge piece of our our
biomass Market
um I provided with you a a copy of the
state or a copy of the Timber tax
records for the state and you'll see in
there gives you a summary of kind of all
the wood that's harvested by county and
you'll see when you compare this tonnage
against what that is it is it's pretty
it's pretty big the other piece is that
Sawmills use this market for Mill waste
be it sawdust hardwood bark and Chip
slabs
um there was in and again I appreciate
some of the earlier comments about
modern wood heat we support that modern
wood heat are like wood pellet boilers
things of that nature but again to put
it in perspective and when you're
looking at the state as a landscape and
you're trying to manage this landscape
um modern wood heat is is a small but
growing portion of the state's low-grade
wood Market but again in the context of
the broader landscape
Burgess is a is a very very important
piece of that so loss of Burgess for
modern wood heat or some of these other
applications to kind of supplant that
loss would take
I I would dare say many many many years
so as a landowner or a land manager
whether you're managing for
sustainability managing you know Forest
pest situations
um Burgess is is critical
the you know our interest in the bill in
the original Bill appears in lines four
um
four through on pages four uh through
eight and again on 15 where it talks
about Forest Health supporting of the
industry and then on the amendment on
page two
starting at page 11 that discusses
public you know economic contributions
and public interest and I I wanted to
just
you know there are this idea of public
interest appears also in the RPS law as
well as LIPA and this is a you know an
issue that I think is important to kind
of bring kind of bring forth in in the
hearing and get it on the record that
one of the things about public interest
or one of the considerations is fuel
diversity and having having energy that
is is cleaner but and and and uh it is
renewable and like I said this this
facility checks all those boxes
um and I'm happy to hear some of the
discussion that was that was just I just
witnessed about the concept of looking
at some other Alternatives be it default
or things of that nature I've spent some
quite a bit of time this summer working
with the chairman when he had some
subgroups looking at this and I do think
there may be a solution in that
um and I would I would hate to see us
come up with a solution after this
facility is shuttered so I think the
given the opportunity to keep this
facility going
keep it going as we continue to look at
are there Solutions I think is critical
and I would argue that it is part of the
public interest it's a big piece of the
economy in the North Country frankly
it's a big piece of the economy
Statewide when you look at those Timber
tax records and you see where this
biomass is being harvested
so again I will
that the last point I want to raise is
um and although it hasn't come up I just
want to remind folks that you know when
it comes to carbon neutrality and some
of the environmental issues the EPA has
has determined that biomass is in fact
carbon neutral and as I have said before
when you look at our state and you look
at our forest and our growth and our
Timber growth and this is using USDA
Forest Service data we continue to grow
more wood than we Harvest or dies
through more natural mortality so one of
one of the most cleanest and best
standards for sustainability in carbon
neutrality which all that standing
Timber is stored carbon is the fact that
we continue to accrue more Forest across
the state and so with that I'll I'll
conclude my testimony I appreciate your
time this morning and I truly appreciate
your efforts to to try to keep this
important Market Market viable thank you
thank you as usual very informative and
succinct We Appreciate You testifying
thank you I have a lot of questions here
for you I see so we'll start with
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question and thank you for
your testimony actually the paperwork
you handed out to us
question I have is in regards to
um as as we all know locally in the and
nationally on the news the Silicon
Valley Bank collapsed and myself
personally I've always been against bank
bailouts and I'm conflicted here because
with when you're talking about a bailout
you're hoping that a business can
continue on without having to come back
take another bite in the Apple what can
you tell us that if this looks like a
bailout and if it was how would you know
or how can you verify that you wouldn't
be coming back again in a couple years
for another bite at the Apple
great question and you know it's
I guess the in to use your term you know
the bailout or subsidies another term
that's that's frequently used I would
argue that this facility in particularly
in today's markets with the volatility
that we see
um it's just like any stock portfolio
you have underperformers and you have
older above performers or high
performers I should say in having a mix
over time will serve you well I I
contend or argue that when you look at
energy and you look at energy markets
having that diversity and again I come
back to the public interest and maybe
there's a price to that diversity but
over time I would argue that as a
consumer and taking that volatility out
so we're not subject to the fluctuations
that we see in natural gas there is a
value to that how you quantify that is
the trick and that is the difficult part
but to have Burgess up there and and the
other you know Bridgewater power
producing power when we see when we have
an Arctic vortex in their shaving some
of that you know steep curve on the
natural gas piece I think there's a
value to that that's why I'm I'm
encouraged to hear some of the
discussions when we look at Vehicles
like the default power and other ways to
say all right yes this is this is more
expensive than on a day like today where
natural gas is abundant and there isn't
a huge energy energy demand given the
the temperature
but when we need it we want to make sure
it's there so that we can have it so how
do we how do we make that bridge how do
we figure it out
it's not a clear answer to your question
I wish as you heard probably many times
already I know you have there's no
Silver Bullet but I do think there's
value in it just like having a
diversified stock or Investment
Portfolio this is part of our energy
portfolio
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so this is in respect
to you representing the Timberland
Owners Association
if Burgess were to close if
what would actually be the effect upon
the Timberland owners
so that the impact on Timberland owners
the owner the landowners themselves
there is a what what it does we would
lose
several things right out of the gate one
we would those landowners out there
trying to do having Forest management
plans trying to execute Forest
management plans
that involve weeding and thinning
removing diseased or damaged trees those
the ability to do that would be much
much more difficult and costly and in
many instances unable to because you
literally have no place to take that
wood
certainly from a cost-effective
standpoint you'd have no place to take
it and so for a landowner
and I may have you know
eighty hundred thousand acres I have a
have this acreage I need a home for all
species all grade of wood this Market
takes that
wood that's unable to produce Lumber
Market goes away I have a management
plan I call up Chopper Bob to come in
and do my Timber sale yes Chopper Bob
chopper Bob comes in and he says Jason
great Timber I can cut that tree that
tree but that red maple over there
that's twisted bro you know that got
damaged in the ice storm can't touch it
I don't have any place to take it and so
as a landowner what I'm faced with is
okay Chopper Bob do you come in and high
grade and take the best and now I have a
stand that's left but nothing but weeds
or do I or do I tell Chopper Bob
you know come back another day how do we
you know or let's not do it
when the when the biomass plants closed
uh after the The veto battle several
years ago we saw an immediate
contraction and logging capacity
Chopper Bob that maybe had two Crews
laid one off and now has one and so
again we have situations where
landowners are having a difficult time
attracting loggers to come finding
loggers that have bodies that can come
and cut the wood
um so there that's kind of the the
immediate
the immediate impact that we'll see the
other is for Sawmills that are still
trying to manage their Mill waste I have
I have members of Mills I mean some of
these Mills to put it in perspective
produce a couple tractor-trailer loads
of wood chips a day so you start this is
not stuff you can just pile it out back
for a couple weeks you've got to do
something with it
um and so they they also run into
management problems with that
uh I'm really referring specifically to
Burgess I mean it's not the only biomass
plant out there so if Burgess were to
close how dire would these effects be
they would be they would be pretty dire
I mean Burgess 750
000 Green tons
the only the other biomass plant that's
running is a couple hundred thousand
green tons
so that
and again look at the timber tax data
that you have from the Department of
Revenue
that gives you a perspective of the
importance of this facility in that
Marketplace
representative merner has a question
yeah just to follow up on this uh I
represent a big portion of the North
Country all the unincorporated towns and
everything and when this the biomass
closed three years ago we saw an
immediate impact on the timber industry
although it looks like bombs go off if I
wish I had film of in Milan like the
thousands of Acres they just come in and
take the good wood and they leave in
everything else because there's no
market and the price went down I don't
know Jason it probably quote the price
it went way down in one year and this
was the only show in town
that we had so it is it had an immediate
impact because we had five of the
biomass plants in the state that closed
so
um so it it will only get worse than
what because we're already seeing it in
the North country
not doing the timber management that
they could do they can't afford to do it
there's no market for that low-grade
wood and that's the majority of the
clearing is the low-grade wood
further questions from the committee
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um thank you for your testimony and I'm
just wondering how do you square that
this bill is good for the four state
forestry industry with the previous
testimony that it is not in the best
interest of the rate payers so I guess
my question is does your industry factor
in rate payers in its determination of
support
certainly
Sawmills are huge huge electricity
consumers
um and we've had these discussions at in
our board of directors rooms because
I'll have Sawmill owners that'll come in
and say I've got a huge load of
electricity I've got a lot of conveyors
I've got a big saw I've got cranes and
again they come back and I think part of
it is Yankee pragmatism they come back
and they they say let's take a look at
this let's take a step back and look at
what I had talked about earlier about
the the the uh the fact that we have a
local homegrown power that also helps
provide a hedge against some of the
volatility that we see particularly in
recent months with the natural gas
market and so I think when we look at it
and and we are rate payers and we are
big rate payers particularly in many
rural communities we look at it and say
is the cost worth the benefit and we say
yes and that's how we Square it Square
it and we've again we've had this
discussion we've had a lot of
discussions had our board of directors
and we always come back to that answer
and that's a that's a great question
thank you
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um my question has to do I want to go
back to your mention of the um modern
wood heating industry and you know the
wood pellet industry
um
and as far as I'm aware there's
one large uh pellet manufacturing plant
in the state down in Jaffrey right New
England would pellet uh I'm wondering
how
it has there ever been a proposal or has
there ever been discussion at least
around the prospect of
um investment some you know an investor
group
um uh establishing a a pellet plant in
the North country where the enormous
supply of of wood is and would that be a
potential Avenue for you know addressing
this Market because you mentioned that
should buy biomass Burgess go away it
would take a long time for the modern
wood heating Industries to sort of fill
that demand but
great question and there are several
there are several pellet manufacturers
in fact one Sawmill installed a pellet
Mill over in um
over in Springfield the New London area
Durgin and Kroll they put in a pellet
facility and that pellet facility they
they put it in
um
they didn't want to get into the wood
pellet business but they also saw wait a
minute you know biomass markets are
shaky we have Mill waste let's at least
hedge our bets when it comes to managing
our waste and we'll invest and build a
pellet Mill so there are out there
um the other thing with modern wood heat
are combined heat and power you know
small like commercial industrial boiler
systems that's another so I don't want
you to think it's just solely pellets
um there is a study commission
representative Thomas is squirming in
his chair but there is a study
commission looking at this he was this
Prime sponsor yes Doug Thomas but he he
was the Prime sponsor and this is one of
the things that this commission is
looking at again the elite this is part
of the problem is you have a lead time
and you know we have 750
000 Green tons that could be gone like
that if this plant closes and it you
were not afforded any type of lead time
but there are folks looking at pellet
facilities biochar is another one
um there's some other things but it
takes time and the I'll say
representative Doug Thomas's low-grade
commission is which is um which is
sorting through this right now and
looking at it and trying to say all
right where can the Department of
Business and economic Affairs start
putting some resources to it to promote
this but again we have a timing issue
and Mr squirm representative Doug Thomas
has a question
oh that was your question
okay representative Kelly has a question
Mr stock think nice to see you again
good morning so I I we have some
testimony in front of us about repair
rates
um uh you know the cost of this
um and I I haven't heard it mentioned
much but the one of the
Sawmills that generates the most amount
of waste our pallet bills and I and I
would ask you if this our state benefits
from a lower cost of pallets for our
other manufactured goods because of the
ability to Output or to have a market
for the trimmings from the from that
pallet process it
great question in in your your right the
you know if you have a pallet Mill
um again when when the when the five
biomass plants went down
um
when they went down there was this
reshuffling of the marketplace people
are scrambling to figure out where do I
send wood
and there were stories of people sending
wood
up into Canada you know I've got a load
of chips I have to get rid of this I
cannot put this out back whether it's a
pallet Mill whether it's a just a
sawmill a white pine Mill that's sawing
boards or a spruce fur making
dimensional Lumber hardwood making trims
for tables and such I got to get rid of
this
um and if I start piling up out back I'm
going to have issues with the town you
know with my neighbors Etc and so there
is a a direct cost Associated and they
said all right we're gonna we have to
get rid of it we're going to take it on
the chin so again part of this whole
economic chain is that Mill waste and
and ability to cost effectively manage
that
foreign
for your testimony and now we'll call in
the very last person to testify before
the committee before our lunch break and
that is Catherine mccorkery from the
Sierra Club
Catherine corkery what is I meant to say
thank you it's a dubious honor
um
my name is Catherine corkery I'm from
New Hampshire Sierra Club thank you for
being here this morning
um with the continuation of this and the
other
hearings today
um New Hampshire Sierra Club is in
opposition of this bill
um
and it it is it is a difficult situation
but
I do want to highlight
who else is taking this on the chin
rate pairs
when you think about the stranded costs
since 2010 when this PPA was established
and I do not have a complete list
what I do know is on there includes
the Schiller station cleanup
where they're before they sold it off
there is also
the
um Merrimack station
retrofit and then they sold it off
rate payers had to pick up that those
tabs
we also have
in the
10 years we have have this PPA
where
this bill it says that there's going to
be a 50 million dollar
Erasure
but I'm I'm not convinced that it's it's
a 150 million dollar
Erasure of debt
and I think
that that's significant and and the
commission or I'm sorry the uh chair
noted that there's been I think you said
two billion dollars
um
just for the this facility I think is
what I heard
um
I kind of feel like it the rate payers
are the ATM of all these facilities and
that's I I'm kind of tired of being the
ATM
and because I'm one of those people
and this is
this is 75 megawatts
of wet wood
the output of Which is less than 20
percent
of electricity
so what what did Jason say
750 what was it 750
tons of wet wood
um
that's a lot of what one
absolutely huge but I feel as though
that this by paying this in pain back in
and putting more money more money into
this facility are we
hindering other types of development in
the North Country two billion dollars
worth of money going into these this
facility
where is the money not going for
development
is my question and my second question
looking at the original Bill and and
also in in the puc or in the second
amendment in the amendment I'm sorry
uh what do you expect the puc to do
I mean do you want them to
throw away the contract
do you want to change the terms
is that is that fair
is that Justice
I don't I I I I'm I I'm asking you
um
in in other bills
similar
we we heard that this would run afoul of
the Constitution or I don't I don't know
if if there's a suggestion of of
changing a private contract in this bill
but I what what do you want the PC to do
I guess is is really what I'm asking
and
um that is the summary of mine that's it
representative Corman has a question for
you thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Ms corkery for taking my question
we heard from Mr stock about the
implications of closing the plan in
terms of the health of the forest itself
how people would manage it what would
happen to the trees I would assume that
the Sierra Club is very interested in
the health of the forest so I'm
wondering how do you counterbalance that
we have uh no surprise probably a very
different philosophy about how how
forests are managed
our biggest concern is the Public Public
forests
and the
the idea that Forest needs to be managed
is a little less
um of a concern for us
um we'd like to see a diversity of of
trees in our national forests in our
public lands
um by clearing away these you know waste
trees
um that they could be homes for lots of
Wildlife and habitat
um that do not like the the thinner
trees or do not like
um more space
um and so there's there's we have a
really different aspect to that and I
I'm happy to produce any
um I think there's a report that I can
share with you about that
um it that also comes to mind if I could
um
just thinking about
the public good
for the state
what if what if this was not a wood
burner what if it was a a windmill would
you have
authorize the two billion dollars of
subsidies to a windmill project would
you have granted such
generosity
I I don't I don't think you would have
and this has been going on for a lot
longer a long time and you've had a lot
to think about
with this facility and it still isn't
making money
representative Kelly has a question
yeah I'd just like to provide some
context to that the two billion dollar
figure my understanding is that two
billion dollars refers to all subsidies
are given to the original biomass
facilities built in the 80s through the
2011 PPA group I believe that's where
the two billion dollar figure comes from
and in that context uh the 100 million
150 million 143 whatever it is that it
they are in if you compare that against
those those previous facilities Burgess
is doing a better job of managing that
or or closer to the actual market and
you know as someone who grew up in
Berlin who lived through the pulp Mill
closures I can tell you that this year I
am the most excited for Berlin's future
than I've ever been in my entire life um
I grew up there my whole life I've seen
businesses come and go I've seen you
know the pulp Mills close and it
honestly I'm one of the few young people
who stuck around through this because of
that
um The Brain Drain that happened
surrounding that process do you have a
question I do have a question
the the
would you believe that the
the ability for this Pro for this plant
to continue to operate
for the light remainder of its PPA 11
years
just keeps us from going through another
collapse
um and provide some you know you
mentioned the 20 that's going to
um the 20 rate of of capture the the
much has been made about the the project
in Berlin to capture that to clean our
sidewalks with the heat that process
that project relies on the biomass plant
operating but will help us capture some
of the Lost energy that's going to uh
into the environment currently there are
exciting features that about this plant
that are that are
um that that we we look forward to and
we hope that we can capture more of that
you know
um that energy
um but would you believe that this plant
continuing to operate is part of that
and and and and you know
um
is important to the region I I
appreciate you sharing that
um
staying in in a town in a city that has
had hard times I I have that experience
as well and and it is hard and um so
thank you for sticking it out and I
I want to believe
that Berlin Berlin's future is
is bright
um
I I'm a little skeptical but I'm not as
close to that process as you are
thank you representative Brown has a
question
thank you Mr chair initially I was going
to ask about the two billion dollars but
I think that was clarified but I and
maybe I should have asked the forest the
previous speaker about this
if this closes down
how much land would you foresee
that's now for us that might be open up
for development and then might be less
available to the Sportsman and those
that use these lands for New Hampshire
citizens I don't have that number I'm
sorry
Jason is definitely the better person
for that
representative Noel has a question thank
you Mr chair
uh you were concerned about the rate
payers and the Burgess biomass falls in
the in the context of the renewable
energy program that was established by
the state
which effectively imposes an additional
cost on the on the rate payers to
support the growth of these kinds of of
projects solar wind and biomass
hydropower also was picked up
do
do you see the Burgess biomass as as
effectively did you see that program as
being worthwhile in the continuity that
the emerges biomass needs to have uh
existing in that being enough to offset
the rate payer concerns I I don't think
so
um we have one facility
that has
a a crude
125 million dollars
of debt
I don't think there are any other
renewable energy facilities that have
done that I could be wrong
um but I I think they've been more
successful
this facility has has
we heard from the summary of the chair
since the PPA which sounded like a great
idea at the beginning
it's been going back and forth back and
forth when one party doesn't isn't
making money they come here and get a
change when the other party isn't making
money they come here for a change
I I the windmill projects aren't coming
here for a change and or maybe a little
bit
the Solar projects are not coming back
to make because of some dispute so yes
we support renewable energy I think this
is an outlier
representative murder has a question
yes so going back to the bills the past
few years you've been 100 against all
the biomass bills you sent out a
personal letter the night before the
vote because I was on 165 against it
because it was not clean renewable
energy so a lot of this is a lot of
fluff you're saying today but you oppose
these plants
that's been your stance and that's been
you know stance right along we've been
consistent yes yeah when you well
actually you said something different
the day before and then the night you
sent out letters and call people on the
last vote so
um you just go beaten a dead of course
here
I I'm
I would like to dispute that I don't
appreciate this I I I'm not really there
was no question there so you don't need
to respond thank you
Randy Thomas a representative Wendy
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
um just a point of order um I think it
is it does not behoove our committee to
classify someone's testimony testimony
is fluff thank you
yes I'm sure representative merner
didn't mean that that way and uh regrets
what he had to say
uh representative well I I guess we've
we've exhausted our question base here
so that's good to see
so that concludes our testimony on House
Bill 142.
I'm going to close the public hearing
and this committee is now going to break
for lunch and we will return
at 1 15
to have executive session but before we
go representative closure is going to
give us an indication of what the blue
sheet has to say on hb609 and hb142
thank you chair
House Bill 609
the blue sheet it was four
supporting 23 opposed
on line 24 and support
761 opposed
hb142
a blue sheep was
two in support
by the polls on line 81 in support and
eight opposed and uh chairman that was
for both days
Belushi thank you great thank you
representative partial did you have a
question
okay all right all right so we're
officially on lunch break we'll see you
all back here at 1 15 P.M
we ask that you clear the room because
Republicans will be caucusing in this
room for
the next 15 minutes or so
can I can I ask everyone to please clear
the room as quick as you can please
we're having a caucus in here
foreign
good afternoon everybody
hope you had a good lunch if you didn't
get enough for lunch
if you go out the door right there and
take your first right into the little
office on the in the ante room there
there are three
um
batches of cookies
so if you need fortification to get
through the rest of this afternoon's
exact session
those cookies are courtesy of Tom cloje
who had a birthday
on March 1st
Tom is now officially 39 years old
okay so we're here this afternoon to
have executive session on five bills
and while I don't have a list right in
front of me off the top of my head I'll
remember that they are 556
139 257 142 and 609. so we'll start with
house bill
556. I'll open the executive session and
I'll call on representative Corman for a
motion
thank you Mr chairman uh on HB 556 I
move itl
representative Summers
I second the motion it's been moved and
seconded that we itl House Bill 556
representative Corman is recognized to
tell us why thank you Mr chairman uh
this bill has two main parts it directs
The Information Technology Council to
consider having state agencies using
support development of free and open
source software it also directs the it
Council to advise the commissioner of
the I.T department on the ethics of
using artificial intelligence by state
agencies
regarding the free and open source
software there it has some advantages
over proprietary software but I feel
like overall we should be allowing the
agencies to decide what tools they want
to use computers or tools I wouldn't
would not tell my plumber hey you're
using Snap-on tools I think you should
use Craftsman I think we should let the
agencies decide what it is that they
want to use there are also issues with
compatibility the free and open source
products are not always compatible with
existing products there are training
issues you might have to train people in
how how to use them and also there's a
support issue with a lot of the free and
open source software there isn't a
number you can call
regarding AI
um for those who don't know I am a
Dartmouth computer science Professor
retired for a little over a year so it's
been my business to understand what's
going on in computer science and even in
AI even though it's not my own area
what I've seen is that the pace of
progress in AI has increased amazingly
fast in the last few years AI was pretty
much dead back in the 80s and then in
the last few years with machine learning
and deep neural networks it has just
exploded and the we're really at an
inflection point and the pace of
progress is so fast that I cannot see
that we can keep up it with it right now
at the government level the it Council
meets its six-month intervals and I just
don't see that they could actually keep
up with what's going on and as an
example
I imagine most of us have heard of chat
GPT this program that will write
something if you ask it to write
something and I'm told that we'll it
will even write computer programs that
work
six months ago chat GPT was not
available to the public but it is now so
yesterday I actually asked chat GPT to
write the committee report and it
actually did a pretty serviceable job
it's not what I would submit but it
actually did a pretty serviceable job so
I think that just shows the the pace
that we're going at and I just don't see
that the it council could probably could
possibly keep up with it
thank you further discussion
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman uh almost
everything that representative corman's
stated I actually agree with the only
thing I would add also is that with open
source is also security as we all know
most of us that have either Apple or
Windows and you get regularly secure
updates weekly or bi-weekly and with
open source there is no security updates
on these as well as also with um with
open source 2 this is also where the
hackers actually live and this is
purposely that way so that way they can
manipulate Colonel DDOS other kinds of
attacks as well so I'm against as well
Ito
representative Doug Thomas has a comment
thank you Mr chair
um I I support uh the motion by uh
representative Corman and the only thing
I would like to add is I fully support
and recognize the ability of our state
workers and I believe that they are in
the best position to pick and choose
which software product to use and to
manage their program and I think we
should feel that way about all of our
state workers thank you I intend to
support the motion to itl
representative Wendy Thomas has a
comment thank you Mr chair
um I also uh support the the motion to
itl this bill however I do think we need
to keep our eyes on I a AI going forward
because I think
I'm not not sure we need to develop laws
but we certainly need to develop some
kind of policy within within the state
regarding that I think it's going to
become a bigger and bigger Beast going
forward but I support itl for this Bill
thank you
further comment on the motion to itl
house bill 556.
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of itl for
House Bill 556
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes
Michael Harrington yes Troy murner yes
Carol Brown yes David love
yes
JD Bernardi yes Tom blochet yes
James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Eamon Kelly yes
Jackie creation yes Lucia's partial yes
Tony Kaplan
oh I okay I need your
I didn't have you as a substitute can
you give me your name again
why
Sherry Dotsy
Tim Horgan yeah yes
Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas
Carmen yes Ned Reynolds yes chairman
Bose yes
20-0 by a vote of twenty two zero this
committee has resolved to judge
House Bill 556 as inexpedient to
legislate
without objection this will go on the
consent calendar
and representative Corman will write the
committee report
and with that we'll close the exact
session on House Bill 556.
next we'll open an exec session on House
Bill 527.
and the chair recognizes
representative merner for a motion
can you identify the bill please again
what did I say 557 I meant two five
seven
I pick a motion to ought to pass as
Amendment and I bring forth Amendment
number
zero nine two four
each of you should have a copy of
amendment number
2023-0924 H
in front of you
uh representative
Summers is uh recognized I second the
motion
it's been moved and seconded that we
judge House Bill 257 to be ought to pass
with amendment
092824h is there discussion on the
adoption of the amendment
no discussion whatsoever the amendment
was apparently authored to a large
degree okay representative Summers as a
comment thank you Mr chairman um we met
as a subcommittee met with the group and
um we agreed that this needed to be
pushed along however there was some
phrasing we wanted to change in the uh
in the actual bill itself so this
amendment actually just changed a few
lines and we agreed as a subcommittee
there was a couple places where it was
uh forcing it along so we ended up
changing in like one of the last lines
was I believe on page three the advance
warning of 30 days we added and um there
was a couple little couple sentences
here and there we changed out of the
original bill but it was a greed and
subcommittee that needed to be amended
and this was the amendment to do that
further discussion on the question of
the adoption of the amendment
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair
um just to follow up on that previous
statement regarding the subcommittee we
crawled through this bill line by line
and we're in consensus that the changes
that we made were necessary
further discussion on the question of
the adoption of the amendment
representative murder yeah just just to
wrap it up the five people that were
there um Everybody took apart very
active role in it and we all we all came
to a unanimous consensus on this bill I
couldn't thank uh Chris he's not here
today Chris runs did the actual writing
uh he's unfortunately he caught covered
and he's not here but uh it was a great
group and uh made life easy everybody
get along
okay well I'm sorry to hear
representative munzaz covet and we wish
him a speedy recovery any further
discussion on the adoption of the
amendment representative McWilliams
say thank you to everyone who served on
the subcommittee I think that's
Ashen so thank you think well done
further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of the adoption
of the amendment
2-02023-0924 h
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes
yes Michael Harrington yes
Troy murner yes
Carol Brown yes David love yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom closure yes James
Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Ellie came in yes
Alan Kelly excuse me
I'm sorry
Jackie creation yes lucious partial yes
Sherry Dotsy yes
Tim Horgan yes
Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas
Corman yes Ned Reynolds yes chairman of
Oz
yes
20-0
by a vote of 20 to zero
the amendment
2023-0924 H is adopted chair now
recognizes representative merner for
emotion
yes I move auto pass on House Bill 257
as amended
representative Summers I second the
motion it's been moved and seconded that
we
vote
ought to pass as Amendment amended on
House Bill 257 is there any further
discussion
seeing none I'll ask the question uh ask
the clerk whether to call the question
of ought to pass as amended on House
Bill 257.
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes Michael Harrington yes
Troy murner yes Carol Brown yes David
love yes
JD Bernardi yes Tom pleasure yes James
Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams
yes
Eamon Kelly
Jackie creation yes Lucia's partial yes
Sherry dutzy yes Tim Horgan yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman Bose
yes 20 zero
by a vote of twenty to zero
the committee resolves that
House Bill 257
shall be judged to be ought to pass with
Amendment
zero nine two four h
without objection we'll put this on the
consent calendar and representative
merner will write the committee report
now with that we'll close the executive
session on House Bill
257.
so now
I'm going to open an exec session on
House Bill 142.
and I will move ought to pass and offer
Amendment 2023
-0939h which is finding its way to each
of you as we speak and I recognize
representative Doug Thomas
yeah
second it's been moved and seconded that
we judge House Bill 142 to be ought to
pass as amended with Amendment
0939 h
so this amendment
which will shortly be in your in your
hands
is very similar to the amendment that we
looked at
a week ago when we had the initial
public hearing on this bill
the only change is that we made the
language a little bit
more
straightforward
the original version of the amendment
had under
section two
Public Utilities Commission authority to
amend orders
it had
a section one
with two paragraphs underneath a and b
the new version adds a paragraph C
which is entitled new accruals to be
paid for by Burgess
on a moving forward basis Burgess
biopower will be responsible for any
further accumulations over 100 million
dollar balance of the CRF by remitting
payment pursuant to section
6.1.4
C of the PPA it just makes it more
explicit just exactly what we're doing
here that we're forgiving the
amount accumulated in the CRF that
exceeds 100 million dollars
and stating that any future accruals
will be dealt with
according to the language in the PPA
so that is the amendment
is there any discussion on the amendment
representative Harrington has
a comment
yeah a question and a comment I guess
first question is what about the 100
million is that still being addressed in
the terms of the existing PPA are they
still going to have to pay that back at
the end of the term
yes as the language of the bill States
uh
on a moving forward basis Burgess will
be responsible for any few further
accumulation
according to the
terms pursuant to the PPA
and with regard to the the existing 100
million dollars
a language at the bottom of page one
lines 27 through 30 say that the 100
million dollars which accrued in the CRF
prior to the legislature's suspension of
the operation of the cap on the CRF
shall be subject to the terms of the PBA
okay thank you a follow-up on this
um follow-up since we've been doing this
bit with Burgess now for years and years
and years and every year there's a new
reason why we should be subsidizing them
just a little bit longer uh this is
supposedly the fix but we heard nothing
out of them whatsoever when they
testified I asked some specific
questions explicitly and didn't get an
answer about what's going to happen a
year from now and my major concern is
we're going to be sitting here a year
from now or two years from now and
they're going to be back in saying oh if
you just give us another 50 million or
some other subsidy how do we know if
they agreed to live by the terms of the
PPA and not come back here begging for
more money
the answer to that question is we don't
know that
essentially what this amendment does is
it gives
Burgess and eversource some time
to
figure out if there is another way
to move forward
if it involves a renegotiating
renegotiation of the PPA they will have
time to do that you know follow-up
follow-up okay so what happens if the
bill doesn't pass
well if the bill doesn't pass then I
guess
when the current suspension expires at
the end of October
the
previous order pertaining to this
situation will kick in and Burgess will
immediately owe 48 million dollars and
have to repay it in a 12-month period
which would to my understanding force
them into bankruptcy if I remember
correctly when we pass that bill as it
was last year we said now you've got 18
months to get your act together and
apparently they've done nothing it's
just week round for more money because
they they were given warning as part of
that hearing you've got until October of
23 to get your act together to do
whatever it is you got to do sell the
plant whatever and apparently they
haven't done anything towards it just
standing around waiting for more money
as best I can tell am I missing
something please let me know
further a comment on this amendment
representative Doug Thomas thank you Mr
chair
um
I will support this bill but I do uh
agree with comments made by the
representative to my right we have in
the past
given
one chance maybe a second chance this
could be the third chance I'm not sure
but um
I believe that the reason why I'm
supporting this bill is I believe Berlin
um
needs something like this up there I
believe that the health of our fars uh
need a plant like Burgess and I believe
that it affects us a couple hundred jobs
as well of our wood industry all over
the state but I also say that enough is
enough and so I do support this bill I
want to see them succeed this I believe
is and as far as I'm concerned is the
last chance and I hope that they come up
with a good system so they can keep on
running and serve the state and so for
those reasons I will be supporting this
bill
representative merner has a comment yes
thank you Mr chairman uh when we passed
the bill to increase it for the 18
months there was a big piece of the pie
missing uh that was what was requested
in the Senate and the house was an audit
and we got back a very thorough audit
back on the plant and how it's running
they're under a bad agreement that
it's no fault of the legislature or
anybody on the agreement that they have
so we have a better idea of what's going
on there we didn't really have a good
idea when we extended the 18 months and
now we do and and the energy Market has
changed a lot to over the last 18 months
so hopefully things will go good going
forward
representative Wendy Thomas has a
comment thank you chair
um I understand the importance of
Burgess II New Hampshire's economy and
several Industries livelihoods what
bothers me about this bill still and
I've talked to several people is that it
appears to be one law for one company
and it's it's not that's not something
that we're typically supposed to do
however if we support forgiveness
because of a dubious contract
I will support this bill but I'd like to
see an amendment come out of this
committee to forgive all New Hampshire
student debt that is based on dubious
contracts as well
further comments on this amendment
representative Summers has a comment
thank you Mr chairman as far as this
bill I kind of been going back and forth
over it but
knowing that I'm
generally fiscally conservative I
believe in capitalism I believe in free
markets and Marketplace being able to
for a business to succeed or a business
to fail therefore in this case I have to
vote against this bill
further comments from the committee Tom
closure
thank you along with the previous
Committee Member
I'm of the same mind but as running a
business I know a lot of businesses out
there have put their capital in
with the idea that this legislator has
kept it running I will support this
amendment
and I would like to put into record that
the next St whenever this gets brought
up again with the Berlin plant
um there should be no more forgivenesses
because it's right players who are
paying thank you additional comment on
the question of the adoption of the
amendment representative Kelly
thank you Mr chair so I I just like to
say I'll be voting for the amendment as
well
um it's not the amendment that I would
have wanted but it's the amendment that
we got and I think it's a good step in
the right direction in terms of the the
profitability of the plant the plant
produces power at eight cents a kilowatt
hour and if you look at the default rate
right now it's 22 cents a kilowatt hour
they do not benefit from
because their Market their energy is
sold on the day ahead Market they do not
benefit from the immense savings that
eversource is getting by buying the
electricity from the plant so my you
know the idea this the CRF itself was
put in place was a was something that
this puc put into the contract to react
to the other biomass facilities in New
Hampshire
the it was a imposed uh part of the
agreement from the puc to defend rate
payers
I don't think that most rate payers
would be an argument for the two to
three dollars a month in overcap charges
that they are paying for the benefits
that we get as were discussed by the
nhtoa and others here today I will be
voting for the amendment as I said I
wish we could get something better but I
can guarantee that we will have
something in front of our committee
again because this bill just kicks the
can down the road again thank you
representative Harrington has a comment
yeah a couple of comments uh I think my
esteemed colleague there's a little
confused default service rate is a
retail rate that the electric utility
charges their customers they don't buy
electricity at the default service rate
the wholesale rate is we talk right now
in the day ahead Market is 46.19 which
is substantially below the 22 of the two
hundred and twenty dollars that you
would mention per megawatt hour so
that's the first config which a lot of
people have been confused about that
some of the people representing uh the
plant where Berlin said that the default
service rate is not the same thing as
the wholesale rate this is a wholesale
generator they're in the wholesale
Market they don't get paid on retail
rates nobody gets paid retail default
Service rates no generator in the uh in
New England does so and the second thing
is I guess what was just said I find
extremely troubling because we've just
been guaranteed that regardless of what
happens here today they're going to be
back next year begging for more money
and if they don't get enough then
they'll be back the year after I think
enough is enough it's time said we gave
them 18 months they haven't done
anything other than come up with another
plan for to give them more money I think
this is it stop the bleeding now and
vote against this bill
foreign
representative Kelly has another one
so at first I'd like to thank the
representative for for correcting my my
numbers
um I guess my point is still that the
margin on the electricity is very high
it's higher than what the standard is
for the industry my my second comment
would be that I don't speak for Burgess
biopower I am a citizen of Berlin and I
and I'm basing that off my understanding
of the situation
the the idea that what I'm saying is
that we are again imposing another cap
into the CR this we're imposing the CRF
beyond the value of the facility which
will lead to the exact problems that
were outlined by the doe when they did
their
audit of the facility the Burgess
biopower is is run in a very efficient
way
and the idea that they are making
Handover fist for private investors or
for somebody else is not the case thank
you
additional comment on the question of
the adoption of the amendment
to house bill 142.
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr chairman so uh I I am not
pleased with the circumstances that
Berlin finds itself in Laura am I
pleased with
what's happening with the Burgess bio
plant uh and
not necessarily pleased with what the
legislature did in the past
but this particular bill I see as now
drawing a line saying
the legislator legislature is now out of
this process
here's here's the deal
going forward it's in your court to
address the circumstances that you have
so I will support the bill and nothing
further
additional comment on the question of
the adoption of the amendment
representative Nutter
short and sweet what representative
Bernardi said ditto
okay
further comment
besides ditto
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the question of the adoption of the
amendment 2-0
23-0939h
Doug Thomas
yes Janine nodder yes Michael Harrington
no
Troy murner yes
Carol Brown yes
David love yes
JD Bernardi yes Tom closure yes
James Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Eamon Kelly
yes
Jackie creation yes
Lucia's partial
yes
Sherry dutzy yes
Tim Horrigan yes
Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas I apologize are we voting
on the amendment Bill the amendment yes
yes then yes
Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes
chairman of owes yes
18-2
by a vote of 18 to 2 the amendment
two zero two three zero nine three nine
H is adopted
I move
ought to pass as amended
and recognize representative Thomas
a second it's been moved and seconded
that we adopt House Bill 142 as amended
by
0939h is there any further discussion
yes
representative Thomas yes Mr Thomas Mr
yes uh I will be supporting otpa I just
want to make one statement
as long as we are people sitting here in
this committee
do not come back with another request
after this one here please because I
will not support that one thank you
further comment
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um I just want to relay that um I
had I had a discussion with some of the
representatives not representative
Representatives but some of the people
who represented the biomass and one of
my questions was what what guarantee do
we have that once this this uh debt is
Forgiven that they the CEO won't get a
big bonus or that they won't now sell
the plant and
um I was assured that as much as
possible that that was not uh part of
the picture and uh for me that that was
important to know thank you
great thank you
further discussion representative Kelly
yeah I would I would just add to that
that the 100 million dollar CRF as it's
written in this bill it acts as a a
a piece against the sale price of the
facility so there is no value in selling
the facility to the owners if that's the
case the the other part I would add is
that nine years is the time span that
was put forward if the pert plant was to
close it would take the koas county nine
years to recover from its closure so as
a resident of kawas County who has lived
their entire life inside of a recession
inside of other recessions that the
country was going through I would ask
that you understand this in the context
of the full situation these are people
like yourselves from one part of the
Town one part of the state and there are
very few times where the state has the
power to have such an enormous effect on
a single community so I would appreciate
your support on this bill and I would
appreciate on the understanding if this
issue is brought before this committee
again thank you
additional comment on the question of
ought to pass as amended representative
Summers
thank you Mr chairman
if you believe in if you believe in free
business and you know that the contract
that they're within the by the next day
uh pricing is the actual problem that
they're having and knowing that if this
did fail and they were forced to
bankruptcy that this would more likely
end that contract that's causing this
problem then I agree that you should
vote itl on this
further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the question
or call the role rather on the question
of ought to pass as amended on House
Bill one
42.
Doug Thomas
yes Janine nodder yes Michael Harrington
no Troy Marner yes Carol Brown yes David
love yes JD Bernardi yes Tom closure yes
James Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Eamon Kelly
yes
Jackie creation yes Lucia's partial yes
Sherry dutzy yes Tim hargan yep yes
Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman Vose yes 18-2
by a vote of 18 to 2
House Bill 142 as amended by
Amendment 0939 H is resolved to be
ought to pass as amended
so I thank you everyone just a question
before we close yes that is not going on
the consent calendar that is not going
on the consent calendar I will write the
majority report is there a Minority
Report
I'll write one
representative Harrington will write a
Minority Report
okay
that's all we need to do on House Bill
142.
so now we will move along to House Bill
139 I'll open the exact session exec
session
and recognize representative Doug Thomas
thank you Mr chairman uh House Bill 139
motion itl
chair recognizes representative Bernardi
it's sack of the motion it's been moved
and seconded that we itl House Bill 139
I'll start the discussion here
because
about two weeks ago I think it was I
requested that the consider the
committee consider reconsider this bill
we'd originally judged it to be
without recommendation and I asked the
committee to reconsider it and offered
an amendment
and
in the time that has passed since then
we've had discussions about the
amendment
some suggested changes we couldn't come
to any agreement so for that reason
representative Thomas has decided to
move itl on this bill and I concur with
that judgment
further discussion on the question of
itl on hb-139
representative Grecian
thank you chair
um I will be voting against the motion
to itl
um I think that there is still
important benefit to this bill
particularly in allowing hosts or
municipalities that are neighboring each
other to share electrical generation
requirements I understand that the
language extending this ability to
housing authorities and peas Air Force
Base and quasi-public entities was not
acceptable to the group so I have
prepared another amendment that I would
bring forward if we defeat the ital
motion that would eliminate that
language
thank you further discussion on the
question of itl on House Bill 139
seeing none I asked the clerk to call
the quest crawl the role on the question
of itl on hb139
Doug Thomas yes Janine naughter yes
Michael Harrington yes Troy merner yes
Carol Brown yes David love yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom plagee yes James
Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams no
Eamon Kelly
no Jackie creation no
lucious partial no Gary dutzy no Tim
Horgan no Henry Noel no Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Carmen no Ned Reynolds No
chairman Bose
yes
10 10.
by a vote of 10 to 10 the motion of itl
fails chair recognizes representative
Thomas for New Motion
thank you Mr chair in view of the 1010
tie uh I I motion to retain the bill
representative Bernardi a second the
motion it's moved and seconded that we
retain House Bill 139
I'll start the discussion by
pointing out that we've already retained
12 bills so far this year we're going to
have to deal with all of those in
September October
I don't think it's prudent for us to
retain any more bills and so I will be
voting against the motion to retain
House Bill 139 further discussion
representative McWilliams
thank you chervos
um
and I think that it's certainly
something that I'd like to see again uh
it's unfortunately weren't able to work
out an amendment to make sure that both
sides agreed but I don't think that this
is something we would want to retain so
I'll be voting against retaining
further discussion on the question of
retained for House Bill 139
seeing none I asked the clerk to call
the roll on the question of retained for
house bill 139.
Doug Thomas
no
Janine Nader
Michael Harrington no
Carol Brown
no idea oh wait a minute
oh stop yes
Troy murner no
David love nope
Carol Brown
no
sorry my uh I messed up on on all these
crossouts here
uh
JD Bernardi no Tom blocker no James
Summers no Rebecca McWilliams no
Eamon Kelly
no
Jackie creation no lucious partial
Sherry dutzy no Tim Morgan no
Henry Noel no Wendy Thomas no Thomas
Corman no Ned Reynolds No chairman Bose
no
zero to twenty
buy a vote of zero to twenty
the motion to retain house bill
139 fails so this bill will go to the
floor without recommendation
representative Douglas Thomas will write
the report for itl
say again
can we not make a motion for ought to
pass and introduce the amendment
um
I don't know that it would be productive
to do that
it'll just take up time
I don't think there'll be any
all right if you'd rather have it go to
the floor as originally drafted that's
fine with me
yes representative partial thank you for
uh recognizing me uh am I not uh
mistaken in my my mistake in my belief
that recently the uh house clerk has
said we need to exp to examine all the
options on a bill such as this even if
we do feel it's beyond productive to
take a further vote
the house clerk said that if you come to
a 1010 vote on one motion then you can
vote on retain
if you come to 1010 on retain
then you can move on
okay thank you yes thank you
any further discussion on
um where were we
oh we were trying to figure out who's
going to
did we do the final bill yet
did the return yeah right okay so we're
we're with at the without recommendation
stage and representative Thomas will
write the case for itl who will write
the case representative McWilliams for
um and that's representative Doug Thomas
we'll write that Doug Thomas correct
representative Christian will and
representative Christian will write the
case for ought to pass
okay
all set on that one
I'll close the exact session on House
Bill 139.
and we will take a
brief recess while
our committee researcher Christy hands
out this voluminous Amendment
to House Bill 609 FN
I sent it to everybody via email a
little while ago
it's amendment number 2023
-0931h
now before we begin the discussion of
this amendment
I'd like to give everybody
a period of time to read it
and
digest it
the question is how much time would you
like
five minutes ten minutes
15 minutes
but just to clarify so this amendment
that we're looking at replaces 769 H it
does okay
I think 10 minutes is a good start
chervos 10 minutes yes I think that's
appropriate all right we will take a a
break until 2 20. and we'll come back
and address this amendment
foreign
okay everybody welcome back I hope you
had a nice break I hope you had a chance
to uh Digest
the amendment that we're about to uh
examine
so I'll open an exec session on House
Bill 609 and I will move ought to pass
and offer Amendment
20230931h and I recognize representative
Tom Doug Thomas
second been moved and seconded that we
adopt
Amendment
0931h and I'm now going to go through
the amendment to highlight the important
changes that the amendment makes
to the original bill
so we're going to start right on the
very first page line 26.
the definition of administrator has been
changed to mean
administrator means an employee of the
commission designated by the chairperson
as the administrator of site evaluation
the next major change is on page three
starting at line 29. excuse me Mr
chairman just so we're clear when you
say commission you mean Public Utilities
Commission
yes if you look at the other definitions
definition on page 2 line 10 commission
means the Public Utilities Commission
representative Grecian thank you I do
better with concrete examples so is this
somebody who we already know and have
met would this be a new hire for the
commission or
no if you read later in just a minute we
will we will discover just exactly how
that person gets appointed
so if you go to page three line 29
6363 D colon 4 commission and Department
support
starting on line 30 it says the
commission shall assign one of its own
employees the responsibility of site
evaluation administrator
in addition to that employees regulatory
responsibilities
the commission and the department May
assign one or more of their employees to
fulfill the requirements of this chapter
the cost of which shall be charged to
the energy facility citing fund
including reimbursements to the
Department of Justice for energy
facility preceding time and expenses
that a commission and the department May
engage additional legal technical or
administrative support to fulfill the
requirements of this chapter
that text was created for us by the
department of energy
the next page page four
starting at line one and going all the
way down to line 34.
this is text that was added to support
the addition of public members
to the energy citing
process
all of this text
came directly from
RSA 162-8
I should say
and what it does is it in lines one
through
three
it says that the governor with consent
of the council shall appoint five public
members to serve on proceedings as
prescribed in this section
and that all the public members shall
constitute a pool from which the
department shall draw and I want you to
remember that because later on
will
I'll go over the text that shows how
those public members get added to a
proceeding
if you go down to
line 21
section d the public members shall be
compensated for all time spent on
commission business including
compensation and reimbursement for
energy facility preceding time and
expenses
compensation shall be provided on a pro
rata basis based on the daily salary
rate of an unclassified position at the
initial step in grade FF under RSA 94
colon 1-A
i a
now that is exactly the same rate of pay
that a site evaluation Committee Member
gets today under RSA
162- h
the next major change go down to
turn to page five and go down to line
36.
upon receipt of an application the
commission shall inform All State
agencies of such application and invite
their participation in the preceding
convened to consider the application
now this text is important because
previously
there was some concern that only
agencies that had permitting
responsibility would be invited to join
in SEC proceeding but this text makes it
clear
that any state agency
whether it has permitting responsibility
or not
should be informed of a proceeding and
can make comments on that proceeding if
a church so chooses can participate if
it so it chooses
the next major change
now we're going to skip to page nine
which is the section on application and
filing fees
this was a section that generated a lot
of comment and a lot of questions from
the committee
so if you look at the section that
starts on line four and goes to line 10
this section revises the
charges for various Energy Systems
it's much different and much simpler
than what was there before and I think
you'll agree it looks
a lot fairer as well
the next change is down on line 28
this was a change suggested by
representative McWilliams
previously
there was we discussing these as we go
along we're going to wait until we go
through the whole thing
you can discuss them now if you like
um I have a question then representative
Harrington has a Crest question these I
see that you change the amount uh that's
being charged and my understanding that
they the way they are in now was based
on a estimate of cost uh associated with
each different type of thing whereas a
you know a 10 megawatt wind plant would
probably take the same amount as of time
as a 200 or 300 megawatt natural gas
plant
these new numbers based on something or
is it just an attempt to make prices
lower and will they uh be substantial
enough to cover the funding of the site
evaluation committee
thank you for that question the bulk of
the charge is the base charge the sixty
thousand dollar base charge and the
twenty thousand dollar certificate and a
compliance charge
so the per megawatt charges are
additional to that and
upon analysis it looks like these
numbers will be adequate
to fund
the application fee charges
if they're not
will know that pretty quickly once uh
once this legislation goes into effect
and we can adjust them at that point
keeping in mind that fairness is
the major issue here and the major
question
any further questions about that
representative Christian are you happy
with that change
my goodness yes thank you for checking
okay thank you
so then representative Kelly do you have
a question yeah I just uh I believe
representative Thomas serves on the
nuclear energy study commission I didn't
know if they had any insight on if
there's a difference in
things that they're looking at that that
we need to have
for that nuclear which representative
Thomas oh
no no I I do not officially serve on it
I representative Harrington does
well it's ongoing uh one thing I was
just giving on a question is I'm not
even sure the state has any regulatory
authority over nuclear generation that's
exclusively the purview the NRC and I'm
not sure if we didn't issue was permit
it would mean anything because that's
been taken up in court a number of times
and the Pu the NRC has exclusive rights
for licensing nuclear plants
okay
all right so going to line 28 the amount
and the fee schedule can be increased or
decreased by up to five percent that's a
change it was 20 in the previous
iteration of um
of the amendment and that was a
suggested change by representative
McWilliams who thought 20 sounded kind
of excessive
next page 10 starting at line one and
going all the way down to Line 34. This
is the
section that discussions discusses the
department of Energy's role the council
for the public this role
the Department of Justice and the office
of the consumer advocate
the real important
all of this text is is slightly
different but the real important text
that you should examine carefully is
line five
the sentence that this says the
department shall appoint two members of
the public to serve on all proceedings
from the pool of candidates described in
RSA 363 d42 which we went over a little
while ago
so this is where
the two public members would be added to
the process
and there is some text further on that
we'll discuss about
uh what those public members role would
be
another important piece of text to look
at here is
lines 10 and 11. question Mr chairman
before you move on yes representative
Reynolds you have a question
yes uh just
the um I'm sorry if maybe you weren't
there I was going to draw attention to
line 11 where you
appreciate that you've changed language
to say the Attorney General shallow
point an Assistant Attorney General
that's about what I was just about to go
away but but it's preface by the at the
requests of the department sorry
yes and that's a necessary change
because
the commission
when it gets an application
uh notifies the commissioner of the
Department of energy the attorney
general and the consumer addict advocate
of all proceedings
and then it's up to the Department of
energy to decide
how best to
determine how to represent the public
and if they determine that an attorney
general is needed to represent the
public which they probably would in most
big proceedings
but probably would not in small
proceedings then the department can
request that an attorney general
be appointed and if that request is made
then the Attorney General must appoint
that Assistant Attorney General
and answer your question
I guess I was just
wondering I suppose in your remarks they
just said if it was a small one he might
not but if it was a large one we
probably would
I guess I
would prefer if it wasn't conditional
like that if it just
then it that a a public Council was
always appointed
well if a public Council was appointed
to a proceeding where it turned out that
he or she was not needed that would
involve some additional expense
so
one of the goals of this legislation is
to reduce costs whenever possible in the
citing process
Mr chairman and then there's a new uh
yes go ahead I have a question going
back to line five
about the appointing of two members so
this is out of the pool of five and it's
that the the department appoints the two
members
um it seems that we could have a
situation where the department says well
there are two that we like and three
that we're not so keen on and they just
keep reappointing the same too is there
any language that that actually makes
sure that that everybody in the pool has
a chance
rotating pool members there is no
language that provides for that but the
reason there are five members in the
pool is because there is likely to be a
case or a situation where there are two
application proceedings going on
simultaneously
so you need a big pool in order to find
two public members you couldn't ask the
same two public members to serve on both
applications or at both proceedings that
would be too much
work for them so uh
you you create a pool of five and this
is the way it worked under RSA 162h and
then from that you extract members as
necessary for a proceeding
does that answer your question okay
down on line 29 this is a new paragraph
that was added to make sure that the
Department of Justice can be reimbursed
for any time that it spends on an energy
facility proceeding
and this is language that pretty much
came from RSA 162h as well
representative McWilliams
so the wording on line 29
is
missile Justice gets reimbursed for
preceding time expenses by any associate
attorney general with respect to any
application or other proceeding so far
I'm with you concerning an energy
facility
and then the last couple of words shall
not be subject to reimbursement that
doesn't really jive with the rest of the
sentence it doesn't really make sense
the way it's written there
I see what you're saying and uh that
does look
see if I can try to parse this sentence
to see what it's really trying to say
although to uh representative Reynold's
earlier comments
um I don't know that you need to request
the commissioner of the Department of
energy to approve the Attorney General
appointing an Assistant Attorney General
if this is going to be reimbursed by the
applicant
I would say that it makes sense to just
have an Assistant Attorney General on
every docket
even dockets where they're not needed
I think they're probably needed on every
docket
it may be limited time need shouldn't
somebody be be looking at that question
though and deciding before
that's what the department of energy
will do
I I would disagree I would say that this
um the role of the Assistant Attorney
General
um which is obviously assisting in the
proceeding and Advising the commissioner
of the department I would say that role
is necessary for each SEC proceeding
so you understand don't you that the
role of the Attorney General would be
simply to interpret
legal language
on the proceeding
they wouldn't be taking an advocacy
position on
any issue it would strictly be there to
interpret legal language
okay so this Harkens back to a previous
Amendment we looked at where the
Attorney General's Assistant Attorney
General was going to be a public
Advocate and that's been taken out of
this bill
so it says at the request of the
commissioner of the department the
Attorney General shall appoint an
Assistant Attorney General to advise the
commissioner of the department and
assist the department in any proceeding
so if it's paid Council from the
Department of energy the Department of
Justice and offers Office of the
consumer Advocate shall be recorded All
rights and privileges
and responsibilities of an attorney
representing a party in formal action
and Shall Serve until the decision to
issue or deny a certificate is final
so that's language that says the council
will be all of these councils will be
advocates
Mr chairman is is the term public
counsel in
the amendment because I think that's
what we're getting at
the previous the original
Bill had something like somebody May
appoint a public counsel
and one of our our feeling was that we
wanted it to be shall appoint a public
counsel
VES
there is no definition of public counsel
in the in section two if that was your
question
so that was the the
yes
I just read that sentence a minute ago
so
representative Krishan has a question
thank you
um going back to um
I don't know paragraph four
um where it talks about the doj being
reimbursed
um does that section need to have any
language about where that reimbursement
comes from is it from the the fund from
the actual petitioner or is that
clarified elsewhere
that was clarified in section D4
where it said that the reimbursement
would come from the energy sighting fund
representative Harrington has a question
just getting back to this thing with the
council I understand what people are
trying to say the there is no definition
of public counsel but I can assure you
that there's has been a council who was
acting for the public his job was to
represent the general public and not be
as it could be interpreted here a legal
advisor to the Department of energy or
the commission but rather an advocate
for the general public and I think that
needs to be clarified in this because
that would be a change of what's being
done presently which has been done in
the past
who's the legal attorney for the
Department of energy
might help clarify some of this language
for us
thank you Mr shulock for being here
today good afternoon and thank you for
allowing me to speak
so with regard to paragraph four that
funny language
I didn't draft this but I suspect that
everything after the comma where it says
with respect to any application or other
proceeding
is uh line 30 on page 10.
so I think that is holdover language
from the current provision which did not
reimburse anybody for the first three
days of their work
and it's surplusage so I think
everything after the comma after
attorney general should be stricken
so that they're reimbursed for all of
their work
if
thank you representative Harrington I
think just as a follow-up to what I was
referring to was in the upper part of
that page on line 11 and 12. it you talk
about appointment uh attorney general
shall appointed an Assistant Attorney
General to advise the commissioner of
the department and assist the department
on any proceeding again it sounds like
we're appointing a legal advisor to the
Department of energy to advise them on
the legalities of going forward and
that's substantially different than what
we do now and we have none in the past
where we had a public Council who was
basically there to represent the rights
of the public so so that's that's that's
a pretty big change
so Mr chairman if if I'm representative
Reynolds I'm looking at them side by
side your original bill and the and the
amendment that we have now and and they
they do look the same I think the
confusion perhaps is
the section is headed
Department of energy and Council for the
public and it's capitalized as if it is
a I think what Mr what representative
Harrington is saying there was this
person who was counsel for the public
so that's good
but I to reiterate I guess what um
representative McWilliams was saying I
think my feeling is that you don't not
be optional uh or only at the request of
the commissioner of the department that
that such a person would be appointed
if I may be so bold as to ask Mr shulock
so I I think that the effect of this
section is that it gives to the
commissioner of the Department of energy
the duty to decide how the Public's
interest is best represented with regard
to those two matters now that might be
best represented by having a council for
the public appointed from the Attorney
General's office to assist it might just
be having the department staff
do it in certain cases where the full
participation of the Attorney General's
office is not necessary so there are
instances where
um
the let's say the environment for a
particular project is adequately
protected by the agencies that have uh
permitting Authority and and there is no
open issue that they don't cover that
needs to be covered by somebody else
right
um if there were an open issue that
needed to be covered the commissioner
would identify that he would ask the
Attorney General to appoint a council
to handle that if necessary
and would hire all of the expert
Services necessary to to follow that
issue through the entire process
so it it adds a little additional
flexibility to the process but it is all
aimed at protecting the Public's
interest
that's the framework of the paragraph
great thank you for that clarification
any further comment on this section or
shall we move on to other sections
okay
next session I want section I want to
bring your attention to is
page 14
starting with
The End of Line 10 it says
the decision to issue a certificate in
its final form
or to deny an application once it has
been accepted shall be made by a
majority of the commission and its
public members
so that's how the two public members
come into play in the decision-making
process
question on that yes go ahead
um it sounds to be a little bit uh
confusing because you could take it to
say that it is a majority of the
commission and then a majority of the
public members
uh so I'm not quite sure if one public
member voted against it one in favor of
it would that stop the project why don't
we just sense the public members our
members of the commission why do we even
have to add public members and just say
majority of the commission or is it
intended to have give a veto power to
each of the public members
the reason that language was was
constructed the way it was is because if
we left it at majority of the commission
then that would allow the commission to
exclude the opinion of the public
members
by adding and its public members that
tells the commission that its vote has
to include the public members
and since there's no comma after the
word commission
it doesn't mean a majority of the
commission
and its public members
in other words
the majority doesn't have to be the
majority of the commission and the
majority of the public members because
there's only two public members the
majority would be
unanimous
but it's that's not required it's a it's
a majority of the five members
that is required so three to two would
be the the minimum vote to either
deny an application or accept an
application or an issue a certificate it
follow-up follow-up I just I think it is
redundant and confusing because
throughout the whole thing we talk about
the commission shell the commission
shall require the commission shall
conduct we don't say the commission and
the public members shall the implication
is the commission is made up of whoever
I don't even know who the other members
are at this point but plus the public
members so to pull it out like that
makes it sound like we're treating him
differently when it comes to the vote
whereas in fact we don't we should use
it consistently or just say the
commission with the understanding that
the commission is made up of the
whatever department heads plus two
public members
representative Doug Thomas
Mr chair uh I don't think it matters
what we think the words mean I can can
we ask our attorney here uh in terms of
legal terms uh how that most likely
would be interpreted in court
the attorney answered is I don't really
know how a court would interpret that
but but
um I think there is some truth on both
sides
that normally when you use a term you
should use it consistently throughout
otherwise people will think that you
mean something different
when you use a different setup of a term
okay but the logic that you you can't
have a majority of two
I think would hold and it would be a 3-2
vote I think that's the most likely
outcome
we have another attorney in the room
nothing wrong with clarifying it though
right so how would you clarify um
you might just put a period after
majority sometimes less is more
right
so you have five people on the panel a
majority of the five would be three
that's one way to handle it another way
to handle it might say majority of the
commission and its public members
combined
and its public members combined so just
to add the word combined after yes
members
the reason I think it's important to
make a distinction here is because
the public members
are part of a proceeding but they are
not members of the commission
so
I think it's important to distinguish
between the commission and its public
members for that reason
then if you've followed that logic then
I think the word combined would work
combined would work
we do have another attorney who might
have an opinion on this in the room
that's Meredith Hatfield Miss Hatfield
what do you think
turn on the mic please thank you so much
chairman Vos for letting me speak at
this particular moment I had a couple of
questions this was one of them
so in rsa's 162 H3 that in the original
current statute it creates the site
evaluation committee
um and I think you might need as someone
just said a definition because the
commission the puc will continue to
exist with all of its duties
so by adding public members you're kind
of creating a new citing body a reformed
citing body so there are several places
in this amendment that refer to the
commission and the way I'm reading it I
think you intend to include the
commission and the public members
so the cleanest thing might be to
have a new name for this body or just
call it the site evaluation committee
um
in its new form
because there are several sections where
it says the commission shall issue an
order the commission or any certificate
issued by the commission shall be based
on the record and the way I'm reading
this I think you mean the commission and
the public members
thank you for that could the definition
of commission
in section 2 be changed
to mean commission means the Public
Utilities Commission
augmented by two public members
already
I think it I
would want to hear from the commission
on that
um because I think it might be confusing
given that Commission
in this section of our statutes
refers to the puc you know wearing its
other hats if you will so it might lead
to some confusion
okay well thank you sure and I would
love to have the opportunity to ask a
couple other questions at the right
moment
okay at the right moment
representative McWilliams
to piggyback on what was just discussed
numbers for committee and then reference
Committee in those instances where you
meant to say commission and its public
members
okay
reasonable suggestion
one more question along those lines
um are there any
I guess locations throughout where
commission is used to mean specifically
the puc and not also
the members or
um
probably it would mean going through the
entire 15 pages and reading each
sentence and deciding whether
or the word should be committee okay but
so like in general 363 D3 powers and
duties this really refers to the whole
committee including the public members
not
just the puc right
or are the public members really only
meant to be making
decisions you know making that very
final decision but not really involved
throughout the rest of the process
page three line two yeah sorry
okay good question
another excuse me chair yes
representative closure
not to be late lager this which I'm
going to do
um the page 14
uh the line 12.
when we have two subsets commissioned
and public members
we put the public members in there so
they would have a say
in reality if they were against
something it's always three to two they
always lose if they're
if they vote against it's always it's
just uh POC
who carries
if I assume more thank you
well
that assumes that all commission
proceedings would be a matter of opinion
but there is language in here that says
that
all their all their decisions have to be
based on
on the on the record
which is the Assembly of facts that have
been accumulated during the course of
the proceeding
so
while it is I suppose possible for an
accumulation of facts
to
always be interpreted different ways
by the same people
I think it's probably unlikely to occur
thank you my apologies I was I was
thinking my mind referring back to
changing commissions and public members
it was mentioned if you
call it a committee then they're all
equal no matter how they vote but right
now when you look at it it's two
separate groups of uh
bear with me committee thank you
okay
parent representative Harrington has
another question thank you uh just as a
more generic one uh because it's not
really clear maybe it's in here and I
just don't see it uh The puc Works under
a different set of rules than almost
every other state agencies they're not
subject to public hearings on their
dissertations they're factor in closed
rooms uh and that's been allowed by law
uh when the puc were members of the site
evaluation committee that didn't apply
the site evaluation committee's
dissertations were in public and were
open to everybody so it's not clear by
looking at this which set of rules are
going to apply it's going to be the ones
that in the previous site evaluation
committee or the present ones for the
puc
I think it's something we need to
clarify in here
so which uh Provisions are you talking
about I don't know exactly where you'd
put it but that's just a general comment
and the the puc is exempt from the uh
what do you want to call it being in
public dissertation uh rule that every
other agent most every other agency is
uh not exempt from now so when the P
when three Commissioners meet they meet
in private behind closed doors come up
with the decision document that and
publish it when the site evaluation
committee meets whether it's three puc
Commissioners presently or two or one or
whatever there is no such uh closed-door
meetings all the hearings are in public
and they they deliberate in public so
which one is going to apply to this one
I guess
because it is something we have to
clarify since you're a former member of
the SEC what does the SEC do to uh when
it's asked by an applicant to protect
certain information and keep it private
well proprietary reasons there are
certain things for proprietary reasons
normally the the in the past this was
another question that it was a lawyer
outside lawyer assigned to the SEC that
was most of the time it was always Mike
icapino
um and that would be the person you'd
look to to see if there was something
that was coming in that was considered
uh you know not not to be made public
maybe some type of a projection of
capacity factors or something like that
that the plant might have but other than
something like that the dissertations
where the all the commission members sat
down into and went over the whole thing
and made the determination as to whether
it'll grow not to Grant a permit or to
Grant it and if they did with what type
of conditions were going to be assigned
to it that was all done in public
and like I say normal puc dissertations
are done in private
okay thank you
so the last part of the amendment that I
want to bring your intervention to
representative Corman thank you I'm
sorry to interrupt
um actually going along with what uh
representative pojo was asking
I noticed that there's nothing in in the
amendment about what constitutes a
quorum of this
committee or body
and given that uh that the Lord Quorum
doesn't appear in here
um give given that the typical
definition of Quorum would be a majority
then would it be possible for this body
to meet with just the puc Commissioners
and not the members of the public and
then vote on something in in that
configuration
as currently written I would say yes the
answer to that question is yes
representative Reynolds thank you Mr
chairman
um while while I'm not an attorney
um as you we've already noted we have we
have several here in the room but I
think that the and I think
representative Harrington for bringing
up what he just brought up
um
about
the fact that the SEC had rules that
applied to it and I'd like to point out
remind I guess everybody that that
um
um Miss Hatfield in her testimony uh
written testimony to us made the very
point in writing that that
representative Harrington just explained
that
you know about the requirement of the
SEC to operate in public and decide in
public so that says to me that we we
need to do more work to Define I think
a committee
that is separate from the commission
because the commission may you know
Opera deliberate in private and
obviously that's counter two and I want
to say I appreciate your
um
your efforts here in the amendment to
you know have public members be
part of the deciding body
so I think we've got some more work on
the amendment to do to
bring back something called a committee
site evaluation committee perhaps
um so that both of these things are
addressed in the Quorum issue and the
voting issue and the and the operating
in public
thanks thank you for your comment
so moving on to the rest of the
amendment that I want to draw your
attention to on page 15.
there's new text about
the what happens during the transition
period between
any applications that are being in any
proceedings that are happening based on
RSA 162h
and any
and the changeover to proceedings to
under
363 d
363 D so this transition language
explains what exactly what happens there
and then starting on line 36
there is text that specifies that the
rules that are already in place that
were written under RSA 162 h
shall apply
and be enforced by the puc
going forward until such rules are
expired or they are amended or replaced
via a new rule-making process
and that rule making process would be
subject to the
gel car process The Joint legislative
committee on administrative rules
so that any new rules made would have to
be approved by the the gel car which is
a
an arm of the legislature
so those are the major changes that uh
that have been made
and um
what I'd like to do now is discuss
whether we could go forward with this
amendment or not
and I would like to start
by reminding all members
that right now the state of New
Hampshire
is a energy project citing desert
it is so difficult to get a project
passed in New Hampshire that
many developers will never try
as we heard in testimony several times
over the course of the last week
major project developers just don't come
here because they don't depend they
don't believe that the citing process
is predictable enough
for to Warrant spending a substantial
amount of capital
to try to cite an energy project in this
state
so I think the real question before us
here is
do we
allow that situation to continue for an
indefinite period of time
while we quibble over a few small
details
or do we move this legislation forward
where many of those details can be
resolved
in the Senate
and through the administrative rules
development process
I think that's the essential question we
Face here today is it time to move this
process forward or shall we wait
continued
tweaking and tinkering with
a possible solution
and possibly
delay Future Energy projects even more
than they might already be delayed
we know we have offshore wind that wants
to be developed
off our Coastline we know there's going
to be citing
projects involved with that offshore
wind
we know that
the coal plant in Beau is being eyed as
a site to
create
hydrogen and then use that hydrogen you
create hydrogen using solar panels and
then use that hydrogen to generate
electricity
do we want to delay that project from
happening by dragging our feet on making
a change to the site evaluation process
I think those are the questions we need
to wrestle with
and I'd like to get everybody's
perspective on that idea representative
Doug Thomas has a perspective
thank you Mr chair first I would like to
remind
the audience that
Center Waters is very much in favor of
this bill and would like it to see pass
but hearing from what for judging from
what I've been I've been hearing here I
have a question for the chair if
these comments that were made today
were is it possible to put them into one
more last Amendment
realizing that we have a deadline of
Wednesday noon time
is it possible to
recess this exec meeting to Wednesday
morning with a new Amendment from OLS
and and with the understanding that if
we get everything that was put in here
today that we can all agree that we
could pass that amendment is that a is
that a possibility
yes that is a real possibility
of course all members of the committee
would have to agree to that they'd have
to agree to come back here on Wednesday
and then we would have to put our heads
together collectively to hammer out
exactly what words we're going to change
and how we're going to change them
and then go off to OLS to request a new
Amendment but it is possible and it is
doable
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair one of my
big concerns with this bill is that it
was originally filed on 110 23 no it was
actually originally filed September 10th
23 the um and on January 10 23 the
fiscal note was entered as no physical
note
the first amendment was filed on March 6
2023 it contains no fiscal note this
current amendment is filed on March 13th
morning when I ask you about fiscal
notes you said to check with the clerk's
office I've heard back from the clerk's
office and no fiscal note has been filed
for this bill so you are asking us to
support a bill and we're flying blind as
far as finances are concerned
thank you for that comment do you
remember uh in the introduced version of
the bill because I don't have it right
in front of me what the uh language at
the end of The Bill said about a fiscal
note it's a department of energy and
Justice and judicial branch have been
contacted
is that what you're talking about yes
would you like to see oh I no I don't
need to see it I just wanted to know
what departments were responsible for
right so we have not heard from the
Department of energy and Justice energy
and Justice or energy Justice and
judicial branch
well fortunately we have the department
of energy here with us today
perhaps they'd like to tell us what the
status of any fiscal note for this bill
might be
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the record Chris
sounds Deputy Commissioner of the New
Hampshire Department of energy
um
given the uh fluid nature of the
Amendments and the conversations related
to this bill we just saw the copy of
this bill today it would be
difficult for us to make that estimation
sitting here in the room although I am
certain we could provide you with that
information
you know by tomorrow morning if that was
something that was was needed
that could be very helpful
would that satisfy you representative
um I can't vote on any kind of a bill
unless I see the financial impact so yes
it would if that that would be helpful
thank you and what about the judicial
branch are you going to contact them
who I actually I'm asking the chair I
thought that was his responsibility but
if you want to take that question go
ahead
no I would I would just say uh you know
I don't know the extent to which they're
they they as an agency would need to
weigh in
um
I think the Attorney General would have
to weigh in on this would he not or
would I was just referring to the
judicial branch there okay
I believe the legislative budget office
is the entity that
contacts other departments to get
information about a fiscal note
so maybe the legislative budget office
is the one who thought that the
Department of Justice might need to be
con contacted
if the truck's Department of Justice
that's the Attorney General's office but
the judicial branch has was contacted
and
they would probably say indeterminable
I'm not really sure
uh
how much impact it has on the judicial
branch some
thank you representative Oregon remember
you have to be recognized to speak
uh represent Mr shulock so if I may the
difficulty in preparing a fiscal note is
in part because the workload of the SEC
is entirely unpredictable right and so
when you look at the fee structure that
you have here
you know what you're going to charge
people but you don't know how many
people are going to show up
right meanwhile one of the goals of of
the study committees and I think of this
bill is to make sure that the SEC is not
just a pop-up agency that materializes
only when there's something to decide
and then goes away it's to give it
stability and to make sure that there
are professional staff
at all times
who can constantly educate themselves
and and come up to speed so that when a
project does appear they're ready to go
no so I think when you look at the way
that this bill is set up
the way that it's set up is to have
those stable positions hired and paid
for out of the utility assessment
right and we have those employees or we
we at least have the positions for the
employees necessary to do that right
plus there is the the current uh
administrator who nobody intends to get
rid of he would just go to the puc and
be a POC employee doing that work right
so you know we can look at the
the the grade levels and the salaries of
the people who will be working on it but
what we're not going to know uh going
forward is how much of their time
exactly they're going to be spending on
SEC work and how much of their time
exactly they're going to be spending
doing utility assessment work the
regular regulation regulation of Public
Utilities
right so anything we do is going to be a
guess based upon probably uh
five positions I I understand that and
thank you for that explanation however
isn't that kind of your um your
responsibility to make your best guess I
mean we've had this bill since
um last year November uh September of
last year
and we again we're Flying Blind we have
no idea we have no best guess we have no
guests we have nothing so the the
original Bill did not provide any
support at all for for the SEC it didn't
mention who the employees would be or
how they would be paid we're we are
actually doing our very best to make it
fluid and to make sure that there is
funding available and people available
to do this but it's it's just a rolling
Target at this point
okay thank you for that information
representative Lucius partial is
recognized
representative Kelly is recognized sorry
Mr chair I just had a question about
what you mentioned on part 15. I didn't
know the the RSA 162h carryover
um wording I didn't know if that was
meant to bring over the five public
members who are currently serving on the
site evaluation committee or if they
would be wiped clean and have to
reappoint
because of the language in the other
section says that they have to be
appointed in staggered terms for their
initial term and I wasn't sure if that
would you know and then they have to do
training so I wasn't sure if that would
preclude the public members from serving
on the initial meetings if the if
they're taking over the responsibility
site evaluation can you committee
immediately I just didn't know if that
language meant that or if I'm
uh just I was just clarifying question
not sure I fully understand your
question
are you asking if
the pool of five public members which
presumably would be
appointed
after this legislation takes effect
after it's
effective date are you asking if they
would be appointed quickly enough to
make it onto any application proceeding
that's that might come down the pike
yes partial so it's I guess it's two
parts so it's a first part we have five
public members of the site evaluation
committee currently who are selecting a
similar two-person process to to vote
with those five members immediately
become the five members on this new
commission and I understand because of
the 162h carryover language or is it
they have to be pointed and we have to
appoint starting with two initially
well this uh language doesn't say one
way or the other whether they would they
would come over from the 165 162h
process but it would be a logical place
to start to uh
make those five members then the five
members of the pool under 363 D yes
representative Harrington has a question
yeah um a couple of comments actually
um first something was just mentioned
I'm surprised some of the people in the
back in the room didn't jump up and down
when they heard this but what was just
stated is that the employees that are
going to be working on the for the
Department of energy doing site
evaluation committee work are going to
be funded out of the assessment or maybe
not Department of energy the puc are
going to be the assessment on utilities
and I don't think because a lot of these
projects have nothing to do with
utilities I mean like for example
propane storage in Newington we
shouldn't have the rate payers be paying
for anybody doing that maybe I
misunderstood that part the second thing
I wanted to bring up again is I'm just
I'm not clear we need public members on
this we don't do it for anything else
somebody I used the example I gave
before the Tuscan Village down in Salem
it's like thousands of acres and all
sorts of apartments and COA and uh
I don't know this is restaurants
theaters movie theaters the shopping
centers everything you can think of and
yet there's a whole mess of boards and
agencies will be involved in permitting
that none of which have public members
on them they have elected or appointed
members and since we're going to have a
public Council here
um or which seems like it's in the
statute I don't see why we have to have
public members I think it just kind of
bogs it down we don't do it for anything
else that I'm aware of will we appoint
public members that are voting members
and issue certificates that come out of
the state of New Hampshire
so
utility assessment one I think David's
going to address it sounds like
so I want to read you what it says in
section D4 on page three
says the commission shall assign one of
its own employees the responsibilities
of site evaluation administrator in
addition to that employee's regulatory
responsibilities
the commission and the department May
assign work to one or more of their
employees to fulfill the requirements of
this chapter
the cost of which shall be charged to
the energy facility citing fund so I
think what Mr shulock was saying is that
there will be Department employees in
the department of energy who when they
are not working on energy sighting
projects
we'll get there
their paycheck from utility assessments
funds that the the department gets for a
utility assessment work is that correct
so the way that it would be set up is
that all of these employees their basic
employment would be as Department
employees or puc employees
and
we had to make sure I mean when
that there would be sufficient
regulatory work for them to do to
justify the positions right that's part
of the reason why it would take so long
to do
a fiscal note because we have to to
assure that these employees will be
doing legitimate work right regulatory
work under that regulatory assessment
right whenever and then whenever they do
citing work they would simply build that
work their time all their overhead to
the SEC fund right and it would be paid
out of that fund it's an accounting
measure to make sure that would be doing
time sheets essentially to make sure
that the proper funds are used for the
work that's done
representative Harrington does that
answer your question
well to some extent but it brings up
another one it sounds like we have
employees that are going to be there
doing something that they really don't
have to do because when a site
evaluation application is received
they'll stop doing whatever it is they
were doing and work on that for the next
six months or something so why do we
need them then when they're going to go
back and if no site evaluation work
comes then these people are going to be
doing work that's not really necessary
because if we can pull them off it for
six months I mean is it really uh
necessary I just that seems like a
strange way to go about looking at I
don't know if there's a better way but
it just strikes me as uh that if they're
they're doing a regulatory function and
then we're going to say okay stop doing
your regular job for the next six months
go do this makes me wonder about how
important their first regular job was if
they can put it just turn it off for six
months or sometimes longer
there's plenty of the work to go around
we have a lot that we can do I think one
of the complaints that we've we've heard
certainly in the in the audience is that
people don't think that the Public
Utilities Commission is getting to its
work quickly enough
that's resolved by having additional
employees to help do that work same at
the department
um
at least one of these employees will be
assigned in our Safety Division which
has to increase its number of
inspections over the course of the Year
our federal funding depends upon that
and so we've looked at all those issues
to to try and make sure that these
people will be gainfully employed I mean
legitimately employed doing utility work
and would just bill time to to the SEC
when necessary and and
we'll just move people around and make
sure the work gets done
follow up
follow-up uh do you have any estimate
you have a working estimate of something
you want to look forward and say we we
expect we're going to plan on in 2025 we
will have two applications for the SEC
or three or none or I mean how do you
how are you planning on this
so the the number of applications is a
real uh
we don't know what they're going to be
it's hard to plan for that
representative McWilliams has a question
for a comment uh thank you chair Bose
not necessarily a question
um you had originally said your deadline
is end of day Wednesday if we were to
spend some more time working on and
refining and making this something that
we could realistically vote on I think
it might be noon on Wednesday noon on
Wednesday is the deadline okay so I
understand we're going to have a
snowstorm tomorrow
um and uh this this committee has put
some significant effort into last minute
review but I think it needs a little bit
more last minute review I don't think
today's quick reading and quick
discussion is enough I think oftentimes
it takes a little bit of the marinating
process to really come up with aha
moments and so I
I don't want to speak for the other
members of my caucus but I would say
that I think it's it is realistic to
have another conversation as a committee
and perhaps a break for OLS to make some
revisions and then a vote I don't think
that that is realistic today but it
looks like it would have to be Wednesday
morning if we were serious about coming
up with something so I just want to put
that out there
you are correct
the forecast though um representative
Wendy Thomas has a comment thank you the
forecast goes into Wednesday for uh
suggestions of bad travel weather
okay further comments representative
Grecian
thank you chair
um I agree with my colleague from
Concord and also just want to highlight
that given that this is clearly a very
sensitive issue for the public I think
it's really important that we make a
good faith effort to get a full public
hearing on as close to the final version
of of the bill as possible as we pass
out just so that
um the public has faith in the process
and and doesn't feel that they're being
unfairly railroaded as we heard that
sentiment expressed quite a bit today
okay
let's see a show of hands of people who
would like to work on this
Amendment
and try to get it
get something ready
for late Wednesday morning that we could
vote on show of hands
okay 11.
so how many people I guess that means
nine people would not be interested in
participating in that process
Mr chair
yes
Okay so
representative McWilliams and I will try
to figure out a way to
make some additional changes to this
amendment and bring something forward on
Wednesday
representative Doug Thomas will work
with our committee administrator to try
to come up with a room we could meet in
because apparently this room is not
available on Wednesday
the Commerce Committee I think will be
in here
and but hopefully we can find a room
because I don't think fish and game is
meeting anymore correct
yeah okay
so representative Bernardi has a comment
because tomorrow is being canceled it's
my understanding all the Committees that
are meeting tomorrow will be looking for
space on Wednesday as well it's going to
be a real tough road to get that done
okay
well I guess representative Doug Thomas
and is going to have his hands full
we are not going to vote on this bill
today we are going to
um
take a extended break from our committee
work today and try to reassemble on
Wednesday morning at 9 00 A.M
God willing weather permitting
we'll see what happens
see if we can come up with something
that we can all Mr move forward to the
Senate Mr representative Corman thank
you
um before we break I just want to return
to the question or the point I brought
up before about
um the the vote in its final form being
made by the three puc Commissioners and
the public members whether we call that
a committee or the the commission and
public members combined
I would suggest that we add text saying
that all five members must be present
for a vote
if I could comment on that commissioner
all right
representative Harrington has a comment
on that comment I say this from
experience having served on eight or
nine site evaluation committees that's
doomed to failure because trying to get
five people all scheduled the same time
when you're doing this we literally
would sit around in a room for 15 to 20
minutes with little phones going back
and forth just trying to get time when
everybody could show up so requiring
five members to be there at all times I
think would make sure you didn't have a
lot of meetings because remember the puc
still has other work to do I know the
two
public members may not but they may also
be they may have another job that they
go to or or whatever so I just think
five is going to be really difficult to
get right so um if I may respond yes you
may respond so point taken
representative Harrington I'm suggesting
just for for when they're actually
making a decision that they all should
be they're not necessarily at every
meeting and every hearing but at the
time they're actually making a decision
I I think all five should be there
it's an idea with considering
representative Christian has a comment
may I suggest
consider permitting remote meetings
especially as some of these decisions
are only 15 minutes that might make it a
lot easier to get all five people
together at once
representative Wendy Thomas has a
comment uh thank you just um something
for the people who might be working on
the amendment to consider on page four
line 32 it says no public member nor any
member of his or her family shall
receive income from energy facilities
within the jurisdiction of the committee
are the puc members held to the same
standard
so that's that's accepted language I
mean but why why are we well okay
okay
thank you
it's all resolved I'm sorry I was
distracted by another conversation did
you get your question answered I did
thank you
um Meredith Hatfield did you have a
comment to make on that question
you have another question
okay
yes thank you so very much Mr chairman
um on page 10
um line five
um this is where the doe will appoint
the two members of the public
um so if you did add members of the
public that's how they would be
appointed
however
um right before that on line four it
says the department shall be a party by
right and so I think I don't think a
party can
um
appoint the judges on the case
and so online page four line 28 you
address
how to
um replace members of the public
um with a random draw so I would that's
what I would suggest is that it's a
random draw but it's done by the by the
commission or the new committee
excuse me
um that's on page four
um at line 30 so this this I think
contemplates replacing a public member
when that's necessary
um so it talks about random draw from
the pool of public members
um and it strikes me that a the
department shouldn't be naming the
public members because they are a party
to the proceeding and then B that you
already do have that random draw
language
um so that might be a good way to to
have the commission or the new body that
you might create choose the public
member so I just wanted to mention that
for if you are going to be working on an
amendment
okay any more questions for sasfield
where was that second set of language I
was uh my apologies but I uh your name
representative Kelly representative
Kelly you have a question
yes where was the random trial language
I was looking for 162h has
um some language in there about public
okay has some public about the the
public process of drawing members and I
didn't know if it would just be easy to
copy that over from 162h the existing
RSA about the site evaluation committee
I can send that to the to the committee
stand by
okay before I call on anybody else for
questions I need to
brief the committee on a conversation I
just had with the clerk
because we're fast approaching the
deadline the clerk says that we have to
finish this bill today
we do not have the option of trying to
do more work on it tomorrow and
Wednesday
we have to finish it today
so that gives us two options it's now 20
minutes of four
we can notify OLS that we need a
drafting attorney to stay late
and we can sit here and try to come up
with new language and get it over to
them
so that they can come up with a new
version of the amendment
and then we could vote on it
when that new version comes back
it might keep us here till five six
maybe even seven o'clock
to get to that point
so uh that really is our only option at
this point in time
so do we have any appetite to do that
could I see a show of hands of people
who are willing to stay
um
before I asked for that show of hands
let me just brief representative
McWilliams on the situation I just spoke
with the house Clerk and he tells me
that we have to finish this bill today
we do not have the option of working on
it tomorrow and Wednesday
and so our only option is to notify OLS
today that we will need a drafting
attorney to stay late
try to come up with any changes we want
to make and get them over to OLS
get a Amendment back here stay here as
long as we have to so that we can vote
on this bill
so
uh
I'd like to get a show of hands of
people who are all right representative
Thomas uh thank you Mr chair I just want
to make one one comment uh
I would be very much in favor of doing
that if I thought that it would produce
a result but one of the things I'm I'm
questioning is even if we did that and
came up with good language we're not
going to have any fiscal note
that's that's my concern and if that and
if that's a concern of the others hear
it that in which case that they would
not want to vote on it then then I we'd
be wasting our time
in my opinion
okay all right that's although I would
gladly stay here longer if we could
produce a vote
okay
so let's have a show of hands raise your
hand if you're willing to stay late
tonight and work on a revised amendment
that we could vote on before we left
Concord this evening
show of hands
one
okay we have nine members voting uh to
stay and work on this
that would imply that 11 members are not
willing to stay and work on this
comment um representative Harrington I
think
um you know we have two ways of looking
at it we can get it we can get a rush uh
Amendment out which we know won't cover
everything that we think needs to be
covered and put that out and then go
over to the Senate and tell them we're
going to uh try to work with them to fix
it which is not actually the preferred
way we like to do business but we could
also just put out what we have and put
it over to the Senate and say we're
going to go over there and work with
them on it to try to fix it because I
think the bait one of the beefiest thing
is this the word commission versus
committee it's all over the thing I've
been looking through it and it implies
that the commission is somehow separate
doesn't include the two public members
if there's going to be public members it
should be committee which is made up of
the Commissioners and the public members
um and there's probably some other
things in here as well I'm just not I
don't know if it's worth the time and
effort to put over something that we
rushed through in the next couple of
hours that we know is probably not going
to be the whole fix anyways and if we're
going to tell the senate if we're
sending you something with needs work
well we tell them something that needs a
little bit more work I mean that's the
only difference we're talking about
we're not going to get it right in the
next two hours
okay I'm gonna with uh withdraw my
Amendment
and my motion to
pass this bill and make a new Amendment
a new motion and that motion is retained
representative Bernardi
moved and seconded to retain House Bill
any discussion
representative Harrington
um yeah we've been looking with this for
a long time and I know I hate to say
well we'll put it up one more time but I
think in this case since a there isn't
anything specifically on the docket
right now that's pending uh and B we
need to get this right and if that means
waiting a few more months before it to
happen or I guess we've more than that
six months whatever
um it's probably worth the effort to do
it right
and I think this committee probably has
more expertise than probably the people
in the Senate and certainly has more
time to deal with the bill that's just
complicated because let's face it
there's only 24 senators and we've got
almost that many people right here so
and that's not so you know
representative partial
thank you chair I wholeheartedly believe
with the comments of Representative
Harrington uh to which uh my only other
two comments would be so I would hope
you'd also have time to have some
additional public input on something
that's approaching a finished version of
the bill and the others I'm looking
forward to in a a discussion on whether
how the public involvement uh on this
bill with representative Farrington
representative Brown has accomplished
thank you Mr chair
um I agree mainly from what I heard this
morning
there were so many people in the back of
the room that said we really would like
to see this amendment and think that we
could at least have considered it and so
I think that's a great idea thank you
any further comment
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of retain house
bill 609.
Doug Thomas
yes Janine naughter yes Michael
Harrington
yes try Marner yes Carol Brown
yes David love yes Katie Bernardi yes
Tom closure yes James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Eamon Kelly yes
Jackie creation yes Lucia's partial yes
Cherry dutzy yes Tim Horgan yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman
yes Ned Reynolds yes chairman Bose yes
20-0
okay by a vote of twenty to zero House
Bill 609 is retained by the committee
next question
do we want to work on this bill with a
subcommittee or do we want to work on it
with the full committee
reactions please
representative McWilliams how many
members would a subcommittee be
typically you do five or seven
okay
representative Christian
the full committee would be appropriate
personal
any other comments
representative Corman I agree with
representative creation
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um this is one of the bills that
we've received the most input from uh
from the public and so I would go with
the full committee
okay I think that seems to be the
consensus then that this will be a full
committee
responsibility come October or September
and October
and I will be in charge of organiz
organizing the full committee work
sessions
and we will
come back here and we'll hammer out this
language until we get it right
now you should know that I will be on
gone on vacation for two weeks in
September so the middle of September
there won't be any
uh full committee work sessions on this
particular Bill however we have retained
12 other bills so uh
representative Thomas will be in charge
at that time while I'm out of this state
and that's he will record that's Doug
Thomas yes and he will schedule meetings
for uh other retained bills to get
together to discuss what to do with
those
representative Doug Thomas uh thank you
Mr chair is it um can we ask
I'm sure there might be some work done
uh unofficially over the summer on
getting some new words on this but can
we ask that for whenever that first
subcommittee meeting is or full work
session is is it possible to get some
fiscal note submitted at least then uh
so we can have something to work on
Mr elves thank you Mr chairman
um we could provide that information we
would just need to know what information
you would like you know so what is are
we basing it off of the bill as it is
today with this amendment
and then sort of there are questions on
you know what you would want to know but
yes we can provide whatever you need
as
as Mr Spock said or was said
his best guess is what is what I would
put my life on so whatever your best
guess is at that time I think it's
something Captain Kirk said that
actually uh bone said that but anyway uh
I would I would say what your whatever
your best kiss would be given the
information you know as a up that point
would be a starting point and obviously
as the uh work of that subcommer or the
committee evolves we would be happy to
update and provide further information
as necessary
just for clarity we're not doing a
subcommittee on this bill we're doing a
full committee work session probably
several in order to get this work done
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um just um you mentioned your
vacation um I will be out of the country
for March 24th till April 3rd
March 24th till October April 3rd sorry
I'll take October
April 3rd 11 days oh okay
all right anybody else have anything to
say
we've had a long uh productive day
representative McWilliams this concludes
our executing on all house bills for
stne and I just want to congratulate the
committee for a very long road that we
just concluded so well done
absolutely
representative Doug Thomas has an
announcement yes since we no longer have
uh bills to act on until at least
crossover I am open to any suggestion if
we would like to come here on a regular
day say Monday possibly Tuesday and
either do a presentation on an item that
is of um uh pertinence to this uh
committee or weather permitting maybe
there could be a short uh road trip to
some facility
Perhaps Perhaps a resources control
center that's not a far drive from here
but uh if you'd like to give me some of
your ideas I know one idea that was
presented by representative munz was to
have a presentation on AI here I I'm not
quite sure
when they could get the person here or
or if the other committee would like to
hear that but certainly a trip to say
the eversources control center is always
of interest because of what they do and
if anybody else has a suggestion I'll
take it get some ideas perhaps by the
end of this week and we can start things
going
representative Kelly
I'd just like to extend an invitation to
anybody who wants to come to Berlin I
can accommodate up to eight people
all in their own separate bedrooms if
you ever want to do a tour of Bio
purchase biopower or another facility
see our dams or something else that the
committee is uh responsible for more
than willing to host you and again thank
you for letting me sit in today
thank you for offering to open up your
home to us that's very generous of you
all right anything else
looks like we're done thanks everybody
see you next Thursday
or this coming Thursday actually
everybody pick up your mess don't leave
papers behind